Apparently Aiden is on Dickers trying to justify the doxing stuff.
Let's go over to Dickers real quick. >> I don't read his
Kiwi Farms page. >> Yes, you were reading it while you
were at the bar with us. I'm not [__] read it. I
get the employee cuz I was saying that that night when I was
like Were you not scrolling through
Were you not scrolling through Kiwi
Queen Hellbent >> leaks every so often is is hardly public.
Okay, that's just not like 100 people in that
stop entertaining. Just stop entertaining the absurd idea that
a 100 person group chat is private. Stop entertaining it. Tell
him to shut the up. You're not talking about it anymore. If he
wants to talk about it, he can go to Icy Chat and whine about
it. It is a public chat. Shut the [__] up about it.
Holy. Stop calling it private.
>> Aiden's holiday. Hold on.
Yeah.
which is that he's a
what? Loser. He's just like a
rich kid
Helmet is nothing but nice to everyone.
>> Oh. Oh, by the way, I forgot to say, did you notice
Aiden wears makeup, guys? I went into Aiden's bathroom. I saw
that he has concealer. He wears concealer makeup for his acne.
Do you guys know that? Isn't that crazy? >> Okay, I'm telling
you that I'm uncomfortable having this on my stream. >> Don't
say this woman's name. Don't say this woman's wife pretending
that don't post me a picture about this woman's
>> Yeah, that's Soul's claim is that he basically there
was this lesbian
and Soul told her Aiden's a hugless kissless virgin. >> No,
no, go too. No, I
h
I uh I sent this to Chudlo Logic.
At some point when it's appropriate, I'll I'm absolutely gonna
leak who sent it to me because it makes it way funnier. Okay,
I said that this Chud brought this up this morning. It's It's
rough, man.
It's rough. Uh, by the way, if you don't know any of the drama,
okay, this girl, >> this is the girl who Aiden likes. Okay,
this gokado. This is the girl that Aiden likes. This is the girl
he like kind of confessed to. Now, I think there are logs people
have made it seem on Twitter like there are logs of him confessing
like that she confirms that she turned him down. Now, I don't
know if that's true. I don't know if that's real. Okay, but we
will get into it a little bit later. Man, I don't know. I might
have to just jump into Aiden stuff. I'm sorry that the Aiden
stuff is so good. Nick Shirley can keep for a little bit.
I might just have to jump right into the Aiden stuff cuz I swear
it's so good. Okay. It's so good. So, run it back. We'll run
it back to yesterday. Okay. We'll run it back to yesterday. Yesterday,
um Perry goes live. He leaks that Aiden was in love with this
girl. He leaks a bunch of other embarrassing stories about Aiden
because Aiden He says because Aiden was rude to him. I don't
believe it's because Aiden was rude to him. I believe Perry would
leak that [__] no matter what. I I believe Perry
was going to leak a lot of this stuff just for fun. Purple Perry.
Yeah. So, Purple Perry Gaming flew out to London to meet up with
these guys and him and Aiden and another guy went out to the
bar. They got kind of drunk or they might have gone out for dinner.
They they had a couple drinks and Aiden
basically Aiden wanted to talk about some personal [__]
cuz he I think probably what happened was he got rejected by
this girl or got like slowed down by this girl and he was feeling
like emotionally distressed. And so Perry told him after Perry
went through all of Aiden's DMs a couple months ago when Aiden
went to Malta, Perry Perry jumped on Aiden's computer when Aiden
was out of the room, went through his DMs, and started leaking
Aiden's DMs with Nicholas Dioro. Okay, so Aiden has no reason
to trust Purple Perry Gaming. But he is so emotionally distressed,
he's so distraught that when Perry tells him, "Hey Aiden, you
can trust me. You can you can tell me about this stuff. I'm not
going to leak anything." Aiden
believes him and like pours his heart out and starts talking
about all this stuff. And
when Perry leaks this stuff, the other guy who's at the dinner
comes into Perry's chat, starts flipping the out on Perry, starts
getting super mad without realizing that by just getting mad
about this instead of denying it, he's actually just confirming
what what Perry's leaking, right? And then very embarrassingly,
the girl, Aiden, and the guy, the other guy all come back in
about an hour and say, "Oh, Perry, you're lying. You're lying.
You're lying. Unfortunately for Aiden, he'd already told everybody
else he was on this trip with that he was in love with this girl.
Okay, he told literally every other person there that he was
in love with this girl. So, realistically,
even if Perry distorted things a little bit, unfortunately for
Aiden, he had leaked this to everybody else.
He told everyone else. Okay.
sorry, we are on kick. I can pull this up. I don't Dude, what
the
Why did Hellbent leak this? Her DMs with
Happy New Year. If you have Aiden's phone number, could you please
give him a call? A quick call and call him an Fs slirt. What
the man? Jesus. Sorry. This is real funny. Just real That's really
an aside to be honest with you. Okay,
so
what else is going on here? We've got a lot of other stuff with
this. Okay, now after Perry leaked this, Aiden started raging
out a little bit. He said it was just a joke. Okay. He he says
this was a joke. These are Aiden logs from his uh from his icy
chat, his little private chat room with 100 plus people in it.
Okay.
And he says he says this about Perry. He will literally never
get employed. Bro, I'm just going to link the compilation of
him admitting to being evil to women next to his full name and
send it to every employer in Malta. Now Aiden's joking about
that. Maybe it's a joke. It's still weird when Oh, it's still
weird when you know that Aiden had already been do like accused
of doxing. Okay, so this this is actually just the embarrassing
stuff about about Aiden. This doesn't even get into the fight
later with Dickers, which we also will learn that was a fight
days before with Dickers when Aiden was doxing Lio Convoy's wife.
Lio Convoy is an art community or art commentary community creator
who's done like some weird. He used to like pull weird mentally
ill or mentally disabled onto his stream to yell at them in Discord,
right? And like ruin their lives and call them and like report
them to their families and [__] He was he was like
probably a guy that sounds like there's maybe some bad stuff
going on there. I'm not totally sure. I haven't looked into it.
But Aiden's been obsessed with this guy. And this guy won't talk
to Aiden. And Aiden was like basically using the pressure of
possibly calling his wife, hinting that he knew information about
his wife. And then apparently in Aiden's private chat yesterday,
okay, apparently in his private chat yesterday, sorry, two days
ago, 3 days ago, Aiden had been drunk and he was leaking private
details about this woman. He now says they're they're not true,
that they were fake private details, some of them, but I do believe
at minimum there are some fairly obvious like docsish details
going in there from Aiden. Okay. Lots of people were upset with
him. Uh Dickers was very upset with him and they basically got
Okay, so hold on. This is going to be added in in just a second.
Dickers was upset with him and basically Aiden got pulled into
a VC, which we're going to listen to cuz somebody recorded it,
of course. We're going to listen to that. He got pulled into
that VC and I think he does eventually sort of admit that he
was wrong. I'm not sure if it's in these leak clips, but he admits
that he was wrong. He takes the L. He's going to move on and
whatever. Okay. Then yesterday, Dickers is talking about this
and Aiden comes on and says, "You're lying. You're just lying.
You're making this up." >> Reban Ruben donated $3
versus Predator. This is the I want to see. This >> is
the
AP I want to see. Okay. All right. Thank you. Thank you very
much.
we're caught up to the dicker's call. Aiden comes on, says, "You're
lying. I didn't dox." That's not doxing information. That's not
even doxing because like technically you only dox by attaching
private or sorry, identifiable information to a pseudonymous
like thing online. So, like some anonymous identifier online.
By tying these two things together, that's doxing. That's not
a good definition of doxing. That's not even Aiden's definition
of doxing. He came up with a definition that excludes him from
doxing. also excludes like Willy Mack's wife wouldn't have been
doxed in in his definition, which is just stupid. Okay, all that
stuff. Very dumb in my opinion. All right. Very, very, very dumb.
So, in any case, we keep we keep it pushing. Aiden and Dickers
have like a longer fight on their stream.
they start talking about this goat cattle person. Okay. This
goat cattle person who it was leaked that Aiden had was in love
with or whatever.
Hold on. X.com's goat
Hold on. I need to find her Twitter really quick so I can
Yeah.
So, it's uh Hold on. It's this girl here.
Grab quick picture
for the sake of the Wait, does she not I thought she posted a
picture somewhere. I was just going to pull up the the picture
so you would know. You didn't think Aiden's a total loser. Oh,
wrong person. Hold on. Here we go. Here we go.
It's this person.
is this person. Okay.
So, eventually they bring her back up. I think basically Dickers
says, "Okay, we we'll both leak DMs." Because Dickers is saying
she'd be on your side and she's taking my side in this. Like,
she's way more likely to take your side. She's taking my side.
Aiden and Dickers keep fighting. And And Dicker says, "Okay,
well, if you think she's like equally likely to take either of
our side, why don't we just leak our DMs?" Dickers leaks all
of his DMs with Goat after some confusion. Okay. And then
a it's Aiden's turn to leak the DMs. Okay. And Aiden goes, "Actually,
I agree. She'd be more on my side." So Dickers leaks his DMs.
And then Aiden goes, "Yeah, actually, you know what? She'd be
more on my side." Like, you got to leak your DMs. You said you
would do it. You're so full of He even made Dickers go first.
He was like, "No, I'll definitely do it." Like, you have to go
first, though. It's only polite.
So goofy, man. So goofy. Oh,
and in that moment last night, okay, so basically Aiden's got
a doxing thing and he's got this whole thing with Goat. There
is a subtle implication. So, this Goat Kat person is from the
art commentary community. They've been in many fights with the
Leo Convoy guy that Aiden is sort of like going after, right?
And people are now suspecting that because he likes this girl
and because this girl had a big fight with the Leo convoy person
that that's the reason Aiden's been directing his uh his content
in that direction. Right. All right.
They suspect that. Now,
I will say I can't confirm that. It sounds kind of kind of close
to the truth. Anyway, that leads us into today. So, we're going
to go we're going to listen to the leaked calls. We're going
to look at some of the leaked logs from his Discord. Okay.
I'm lost dog, but go off. Yeah, sure. So, to sum up, Aiden had
doxed somebody. He was getting for it. They got him to back off
of like doubling down on it and thought it was fixed. And then
he doubled down on it again that he didn't dox or that it was
fine. It was justified. He seems to be doubling down on it more.
It's a Tom Fery situation where basically everybody's saying,
"Hey, you did something bad. Just like take the L." And they're
like, "No, you're just all wrong. No, you're just all wrong."
It's the exact same Tom Foolery spiral on the doxing stuff and
then there's this added element of everybody's like leaking things
that are vaguely humiliating to Aiden because Aiden is an egotistical
prick in person. So those are the two parallel controversies
happening with Aiden at the same time. I think one of them is
embarrassing and hurts his reputation, but I think that one's
rattling him into being a total in the doxing thing he did while
drunk where he could have just said, "I was really drunk. I was
really up. My bad. Shouldn't have done this." but he didn't do
it because he's got the the parallel thing with his reputation
being attacked. He is continuing to double down on the doxing
thing that he's correct. Okay, so we've got both of these things
going on in parallel and they're combining to with him in some
pretty annoying ways. Okay, why are we pretending broccoli head
likes women? Because he literally told all of his friends that
he's in love with this woman and obsessed with her or whatever.
I'm adding obsessed.
Okay. All right. We should go to these leaked VCs, okay? Cuz
there's one part of this that I saw and I'm just like, dude,
I'm not going to harp on. I didn't post on Twitter about it,
but I thought I I had a tweet written about it. It's right at
the end of this first one. We'll just
>> Oh, you'll also hear that Dickers and Aiden are in the
same room during this argument. Okay,
>> hold on. People are about to start. >> I didn't
do her. >> You literally did. >> Now he's justifying
the action. Oh my
And this is >> so this is Soul Skiy the second British
voice. We know we know Dickers and Aiden's voices, right?
>> Hold on.
>> I didn't talk. >> That's
Nope. Now he's justifying the >> Third voice is a guy named
Soul Skiby
or as he's recently been dubbed Skull Skiib. Okay.
>> And this is bad buddy. I hate him. Come on, dude. Okay.
How am I not supposed to make fun of his wife? She's literally
>> Maybe by not saying her full name. Full legal name and
where does she do the
>> I'm on my way.
I'm wrapping it up. >> When he says wrapping it up, I do
believe he means Aiden's been wanting to have a conversation
with this Lio Comboy guy. He keeps trying to pressure him to
come on his stream. Right. This is before the debate last night.
This is a debate they referenced from before that. This is I
think several days before this. Okay. And then Dick and then
Aiden says, "If the wife gets to him, like me talking about this
stuff, if it gets to him, then I can finally >> But I'm
not evil. Like he'll have the option. He could debate me or >> Why
don't you tweet? Why don't you
>> wait? I'm not evil. >> He'll have the option.
He could debate me or
>> I can something I so it gets cut off by this other speaking.
I'm not evil. He could debate me or I could and then it kind
of gets cut off. I assume that means keep pressuring him via
his wife. >> But I'm not evil. Like he'll have the option.
He could debate me. >> Why don't you Why don't you tweet?
Why don't Why don't you tweet that out in
>> chill the
trying to sabotage him right
>> I don't think you're being funny. You are trying to
with Aiden right now while he's drunk. Just to be super clear
about what you're doing right now. Yeah, >> you are actually
trying to like backstab
>> How am I trying to backstab him, bro? >> Cuz you're
trying to trying to get him to entice something to do something
his reputation and career while he's drunk. You [__]
>> Dickers literally like does Dickers know this this VC
is being recorded?
Dicker's talking the exact way he does on stream.
Question. What did Leo do to Gokado? Do you know? I don't know.
Actually, that would be a great question. I think there's a chance
Hellbent would know. There's a chance like some other people
would know. I don't know. And I do think I might want to take
a look at that. So, that would be really interesting. If I could
talk to Goat, that would be really cool.
Um, hold on.
Uh, wait one second. I'm gonna send I'm gonna send a message
about this. Give me a second.
>> And soul is just like uh stardust right now. This is
crazy.
>> Dude, can we go to Lia's house and his >> Okay,
this this part gets a little crazy. Very funny. >> No,
that's icky. No.
No. You can't go to his house and gang bang his wife.
Aiden. It's a
You guys, dude. You guys. >> Aiden, are you there? >> Yeah,
I'm here. What's up, bro?
>> Aiden, thoughts on the >> Now, this that seems
pretty clearly like a joke. Okay. >> Yeah, I'm here. What's
up, bro?
>> Aiden thoughts on the uh ice. >> Obviously, not
self-defense.
Lio supports it, though, and so does his
front of the car. >> Dude, I'm posting I'm literally going
to I'm going to like Astro Turf like me his wife supporting the
ice so that it [__] So they're >> that's really
weird. Again, very drunk. Very weird. >> Give you a reason
tox
would fit in super well with these people. Knows all these people.
Brow is in with these people. In fact, I should probably unban
Mal so I can have him on on Discord because I'm sure Mau knows
exactly what the drama is between all of these people. >> What
are you doing?
>> I'm and then I'm going to submit her name to Antifk.
Dude, 7K's profile is somehow more beautiful than his last one.
It's crazy, >> dude. There's a lot of dead air in these.
Damn.
>> 7K. Dude, 7K the goat's just
going away from me. What does she sound like? What do you think?
>> He's gone. I think he's finally >> Wait, he's
in Parliament posting.
>> Get out of Parliament, bro.
>> So, I think this is Parliament is some part of I think
it's some part of Beckett's server, but I'm not totally
>> What's wrong, dude? Aiden, how much have you had to
drink? >> An entire bottle of wine. And
>> he's trying to cut you right.
>> He did. >> Yeah, he did.
>> They They think they're smarter than you, Aiden. Don't
stop.
>> Dude, got >> They're trying to They're literally
trying to gaslight you right now. >> Listen, I don't know
if has as much experience as you do. You have to like
>> This is your fault, isn't it? You told him to drink
a whole bottle on stream. Wait, that was a joke. But also, I
think I did that after this happened. So, technically can't be
my fault or
Why would I have dependically
hyperfixated on running someone's life? >> No, I have a
real life as well as uh burning time on mine. >> I want
to I like I spend thousands to like buy domains. I just want
to ruin this guy's life and his wife. I want to make his wife
cry. Dude,
this is where like I know he's drunk,
but I do think there's like an underlying feeling here, right?
I do think there's like an underlying feeling that you could
pull away
that
is like I I think after these leaks, he probably can't continue
to cover,
right? I don't think >> DM me. I got you. >> Take
it easy, Aiden. Take it easy. >> Order Texas
rights.
>> I'm going to kill his wife. Why would you spawn? Isn't
he like Mexican? Just call that
>> on him. >> The Lio guy is sort of a drama channel.
I get the like again I think he was sort of like some sort of
Discord only
hunter type of deal. I think that's the impression I get from
talking to people
content myself.
>> Tommy's wife
murdering Thomas's wife.
>> No. No.
I is he talking Oh, Tommy. No, the Tommy here. I thought he's
talking about Tommy C. This guy. And he doxes himself. The Lio
Convoy guy's name is Thomas. And he says his name is Thomas.
Okay. Uh, who recorded this? I don't know how you would ever
tell. It sounds like there's a bunch of people in this VC. I'm
guessing this is just Aiden's open VC or something. I think this
one's different. I also misrepresented this slightly. There's
a private call or a call in like Goat Kat's VC that Dickers and
Aiden have. I think this is before that. I think this is while
Dickers and Aiden are in the same room. I think later Dickers
leaves and they have another call where Dickers talks to Aiden
>> Hiring a deep web hitman on Thomas is
>> and then hiring a deep web
on
This is the ICV. There's a lot of people. Yeah, that's what I
figured. This sounds more like it's got to be the ICV because
I think you'd be giving yourself away if you recorded the other
one. Okay, listen. Listen, listen, listen.
This is the big one right here. >> My reputation. I promise
you, by the end of 2026, I'll be known as the guy that drove
a couple to
>> Ah,
dude.
So cringe. I'm sorry. That's That's so cringe. That's so cringe.
That's so cringe.
I'm I'm sorry, man.
That's incredibly cringe right there. Okay,
he says that given where he is right now, again, it's like all
it's just all ego. It's all ego driven. And that's again, I'm
going to I'm going to double down on this because I think this
is very clearly what's happening.
Aiden had like this ego he's building up for himself. He's trying
to he's trying to paint himself as like the best debater, this
untouchable guy. He's trying to build an image for himself, okay?
He's narrative crafting. He's like legend building. That's that's
what's in his head. And what what happened is at at the same
time he has gone
this guy is too young to have an ego. Oh, but he's got a massive
ego. Okay. At the same time, he did something very wrong while
he was drunk. Probably maybe having to do with his like emotional
dysregulation from the gokado situation. And then he's also had
his like ego hit by a bunch of people he was like kind of trusting.
Shouldn't have trusted but kind of trusting. He had his ego hit
because he's like an apple in person. So this his ego is under
attack and he thinks like, "Oh, I'll defend the bad action like
other people he's seen, other content creators he likes. Okay,
I'll defend the bad action and I'll own all the losers who are
criticizing me and it'll it'll be over." Okay, I'll I'll totally
come out of this. I'll be like the the the goat, the the giga
chat, okay? I'm the goat. I'm the best. And I don't think that's
realistic. I think he's just all all the way in the wrong. Like
it is that's how it's exactly like Tom Foolery. He's got some
personal thing going on in his head that's going to keep driving
him to loop on the thing he did wrong when he's obviously wrong.
And it's going to become bigger if he keeps looping. It will
become bigger than the original
right? Like Tom Fullery thinks he was canceled or or he'll tell
people he's canceled for like comments he made. That's not true.
You were cancelled due to the like loop you went into when you
like burned all of your friends because they wouldn't agree with
you that what you did in the first place wasn't wrong.
>> This is the LCO gene. It is a little bit. I think Aiden
can pull out of it. I think Aiden's had a couple things hit him
at the same time that make it like likely he spirals in this
direction. I do think he can pull out of it. I think it's possible.
It feels possible to me.
But trust me, we're not done. And I actually haven't listened.
There's another six minutes of VC that's recorded and leaked.
I haven't listened to it yet. I don't even know. I I've listened
to the first like 30 seconds or something. He just continues
talking about how they're going to commit or something. But we'll
listen to that comment one more time, then we'll go to the second
one. my reputation. I promise you by the end of 2026 I'll be
known as the guy that drove a couple to
>> Yeah, there's like a total hack to this. But I I think
you have to be willing to take an ego hit and basically say you
were wrong.
You can get out of even some pretty bad actions if you just own
up to them quickly and apologize and say like this was wrong.
I know exactly why it's wrong. I will not do it again. If you're
if you're willing to do it, you can get out of stuff, right?
But there are certain people with this kind of like with this
kind of situation who cannot admit fault and you will you will
burn yourself alive like Aaron Bushno. Okay. If you can't ever
admit fault. Okay. On to the next VC.
>> Thomas is Thomas and his wife are going to amic they're
going to amicably decide to leave this earth. So Thomas is going
to agree to roll over and
take his God. Did I want to burst this fat tubby sack of [__]
open like a
>> Where the is Dickers? Dickers. >> What's Louis
doing? >> Dickers is asking Becket if this is okay to talk
about right now.
Give him a >> Oh, he is. >> I'm chill. I'm fine.
Just long as he isn't like advocating for actual
>> No, I'm I'm putting out a call to harm his wife and
his family.
>> Are you drunk right now? Like that is definitely him
joking. He can't tell where the lines are. I just think the overall
motivation. I I think there's some things you you probably can't
take. He's going to be hyperbolic on everything he thinks, right?
He he does think I need to pressure this guy. This guy's bad.
I need to pressure him into talking to me. He does think that
like I haven't done anything wrong basically yet. And he does
think that it's like about his reputation. He wants the reputation
of taking this guy down. Those are all true. I think we've seen
that he's been hyperbolic about each of these things.
>> You know, dude,
your words. >> She's already been
>> He says his name
right now.
>> Well, she does. >> She stopped at his name.
>> So, you've given away her maiden name. Okay, Chris.
So, she doesn't have the exact same synonym.
>> Yeah, cuz that makes
>> And she deserves it. By the way, she's
>> Okay. I'm looking forward to when go get somebody wounded
hard. >> Any day now. Any day now. >> I'm sure that
my convoy has that, by the
>> Yeah. I'm going to gut his wife like a
>> Yeah. And then he starts and go and then it'll be all
all
laughs and games.
>> I don't have a wife. Yeah, but go needs to break up
with you. Otherwise, she's complicit in what in what you're doing.
>> I'm not dating Goat Ka. I'm not dating
>> So, again, I think Dickers may have known at this point,
if I'm if I'm getting the timeline correct, I do believe there's
a good chance, there's a decent chance that Dickers already knew
that Aiden was kind of into this go cat. >> Yeah. I'm going
to gut his wife like a
>> Yeah. And then it's not phon and go. And then it'll
be all all uh all laps and
>> I don't have a wife. >> Yeah, but go needs to
break up with you. Otherwise, she's complicit in what in what
you're doing. >> I'm not dating Goat K. I'm not dating
>> Yeah,
you right now.
>> They do. They know I'm not dating Goat. >> No,
but I'm literally
>> You drill in there, Siden. >> Are you guys still
in the same room?
>> that giggle is telling. >> It is telling, isn't
it? >> Are you guys in the same room? >> Are you
guys making a fort right now?
>> Wait, 7K, can we write a song about Liia's wife?
>> Oh,
dude, I'll literally I'll get Dumpy to make a beat. >> Oh,
this is the best.
>> Lia's wife.
>> Strangling Lia's wife.
>> I don't even need a knife. >> Oh, man. cuz I'm
a
>> I don't think I I just don't think he like stands on
this. I don't know if he talks like this most of the time.
I Dude, I genuinely feel like I genuinely feel like this from
hanging out with like uh Quimman and Perry
because I I listen I know Quimman's like the inverse in this
way. Quimman when he's off stream says like that not about like
like literally you'd be watching content or something. He'll
like comment on how we got to do something about this person.
But it's like he does that off stream. He knows that you shouldn't
do that in like a public way and it it feels like
>> Quan just wants to people sometimes. Okay. Aiden I don't
even believe it. I don't think this is who he is. >> This
guy wakes up next morning and he >> wife with a soda can
>> drink a lot of soda. Dude, this guy needs to go to bed.
>> You got to go to bed, dude. >> You You guys are
cowards.
>> Shut the up. Aiden gets it now.
>> He's full power. >> You know, hopefully
>> the people next to him in the hotel can hear this. >> Yeah.
And what are they going to do? Stop him from Lia's wife.
>> If they stop them, I'll kill her. >> I'll have
to hear that. [__] >> Give this Give this man
his water.
>> Oh my god.
>> Oh my god. He's still going. >> He's still going.
>> He's still going. >> Drive the car off a cliff.
>> Lio's wife's a [__] >> Alcohol induced
psychosis. I mean,
I don't know. It's just
water.
>> You got any?
>> You definitely need some losers.
>> Chill out. Go play. We're doxing
boy's wife or something. >> Punching Ly's wife
>> in her throat. Gonna take her body and throw it off
a boat
and getting eaten by a shark.
>> Wait, do you actually want
>> Do you actually want job? >> I found her LinkedIn.
Do you actually >> Dude, that I really hope that guy is
sober. What is that guy doing right now? Who is that? Who just
said that? WHAT GUY JUST said that? Who the [__]
just said that?
I don't know anybody in Icy who in the walked into a VC. That
guy is banan that guy immediately. Ban that guy immediately.
Okay,
that's wild.
>> I found her LinkedIn. Do you actually >> He already
told us that and he posted like her picture three times.
Look more
>> Was that Lumpy Willie?
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
>> wait. Hold on. >> So, somebody whoever this is
is saying Aiden already found that. Aiden already >> something.
I think
the Aiden we've been working towards this whole time.
>> We finally unlocked like true Aiden. >> Dude,
dismembering L. Oh, wait. Was it
Oh man, that's maybe the only funny part of the entire entire
like Twitter space that happened was uh Stylo is not a fan of
that guy.
Stylo came in after that guy joined and said some and dude Stylo
is not happy with that guy. Stylo is not a fan. Not a fan at
all.
>> Anyways, yeah. Uh,
Aiden's like drunk
and like on a
spray right now.
>> What instead of lo
convoy?
It was Benjamin and Yahoo that we were slicing open like a pig.
That'd be that'd be kind of cool.
>> What? Do you have a problem with Israel? >> I
don't have a problem with Israel.
>> I just don't have I don't have a problem with Ed Wheel.
>> Yeah. Nice try, buddy. We're talking about Leo Convoy's
wife right now. Okay, >> this went in a weird direction.
I don't know if there's any else here.
>> No, she's
bad. >> She's so bad.
>> IRL if you're down bad. >> Kidnapping Lia's wife.
>> What is she is she hot enough to like before you kill
her or Dude, >> are we serious right now? Are we
Look at seven kids. >> I want you to keep this all in mind
while you dox her and with their live
>> Wait, that's what his wife looks like.
>> Ew.
That's Brody, dude. >> It deserves it. You see it, right?
It's like it's deserved. Like, come on, dude. >> I will
say some of these people get a write off just for being edgy.
Okay, some of these people are just being edgy. Like, that that's
all they're doing. They're just trying to be edgy. Okay, that's
it. They're just trying to like raise the bar on being edgy.
Uh you could you could look cringe sometimes doing it. You don't
know what the like the tenor of the VCs are normally. It's hard
it's hard to judge too hard on a lot of it except I think there's
some underlying motivation stuff there for Aiden that I do agree
was kind of weird. All right. It's kind of weird. I think it
all has to dude and the whole thing where I'm going to be I'm
going to be the guy I'm gonna be known as the guy who made two
a couple go like I drove a couple this I'm going to be known
as the guy who drove a couple this
that's
Dude I was just like gh you're you're like cringe it's it's unironically
like the young dude who doesn't realize how insanely cringe he
sounds right like that's what's going on there apparently Aiden
is on Dickers trying to justify the doxing stuff let's go over
to Dickers real quick if that's if Aiden's back on a stream.
>> Um, there's contention on like what you just said. Uh,
and number two, not my >> There's contention to lie or
threaten your kid. >> Not my not my kid, not my problem.
So, if it's there's not I mean, yeah, there is now. There wasn't.
>> So, little background context. I think Beckett and Dickers
are trying to rehabilitate Lio Conoy's image a little bit. Okay.
They're trying to say Lio is not that bad a guy and Aiden will
not have it. Okay. Aiden will not have it. >> Yeah. I'm
sure if he wins this one, if he wins this one, okay,
uh, [__]
goat cattle will sleep with him. Okay, 100%. If he can just win
this one more >> Okay, so >> he can get taken down.
>> The contention is only mitigating. The contention only
matters. You do realize you do realize
>> I'm going back first jumps in. Okay.
>> Probably inherently hostile to you and Lio. um just
because you don't have like a necessarily good reputations around
these parts I guess. Um but yeah, I mean it just doesn't really
matter about the [__] personalities at the end of
the day in my opinion. I just I could not le if actually like
I don't know like it wouldn't matter for my take at all but
>> uh I mean I guess not. I guess not. I mean at that point
just call the cops on him I guess. So sure. Yeah. >> To
think about it for a minute.
>> That was like a wild hidden. Sorry I'm still I said
I'm like sick. >> Okay. Um, drag Aiden in to have the exact
same conversation with Vlad that I've just had with him. Okay.
And to extract the exact same confession that I've just extracted
out of him. >> Okay. Sure.
>> What? What? What confession? Like that's just true.
>> Concession. Concession. He didn't intend any of this,
right?
>> Sure. Go ahead. Drag him in.
>> Or not. >> Wait, he is. >> Oh, no. >> Okay,
here he is. >> And he a mod. He could just jump in, >> Um,
yeah. So, I actually called in here to say that I'm sorry, but
I think that in order for me to adequately apologize for what
I've done wrong, I think it would be good if the affected parties
were also here. So, I'd like to encourage Lio himself to join
so that I can apologize to him directly, voice to voice. Um,
I think that would be, you know, just so I can adequately um
talk to those I've hurt. >> Wait, hold on, Aiden. Uh, we
can have this call and we can arrange this conversation. If I'm
not back into
this, he can call into >> He can call if he'd like. >> Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah, I think that I think that it would be that would
be totally just cuz I can apologize in front of you guys, but
it's meaningless if the person that I've affected doesn't get
to hear it themselves. You know what I mean? >> Um back
to roles, >> but I heard Gilded. Uh
>> so did So did Gilded admit to doxing Lio's wife? >> I
mean, you want like Yeah, sure. >> Okay, so you just I
face I face >> Why are you still on the internet? >> Uh
because Lio uh through my understanding at the time threatened
my >> This is how I responded. >> Doesn't he literally
deny threatening your child? I'll understand now. Now, >> okay.
Through my understanding at the time, Through my understanding
at the time, Lio's wife was supporting and standing by him with
knowledge that he encouraged a minor to film
>> what? Yeah. Lio is on the record on Stardust with his
whatever her name is individual who also attempted to dox admitting
that he told Jordan, who was 17 years old at the time, to film
themselves being abused. Um, okay. So, from my understanding,
uh, she wasn't even in the call. And secondly, what does that
say? He says he told Jordan. He says he told
he didn't say he told Renathan. I don't >> Okay, fine.
Let's just take I'll just believe you. What does that have to
do >> I was Stardust involved? This involves an old call
with Stardust Barbie from the Discord who we all know and one
of >> So, you believe your standard is that if you do someone,
you should be off the internet. But in your case, the reason
you're not off the internet is because at the time you doxed,
you actually had like emotional uh motives or emotional motives.
You believe that Lio had threatened your kids. Okay. What if
it makes me emotional when I hear about adults exploiting minors
on the >> Well, number one, um there's contention on like
what you just said. Uh and number two, not my data. Contention
to lie or threaten your kid. >> Not my not my kid, not
my problem. So if it's there's not I mean yeah there is now.
There wasn't at the time. Yeah. >> Okay. So okay. So the
contention is only like a mitigating the contention only >> You
realize I
do realize you have yet to present proof. >> You realize
I prove the video. >> Yeah, I literally did in the stream.
Pay the attention. Yes, we went through that whole clip. So you
should get back
number two. >> I don't think Lio intended to, but I understood
why why Vlad took that as a threat to his kids. Also, wait. Lio's
in the waiting room. I think >> that's not Lio. >> There's
no way he got >> same account. So it doesn't matter because
uh that video was taken down.
>> And also Lio
in turn. >> No way. >> So yeah, a lot's changed since
May.
>> Sorry. Sorry. I didn't realize I was muted. So if I
say sorry, then I'm allowed to stay online. >> You had
no justifiable reason to do what you did. >> I just explained
to you. >> No, your reason is it's not your reason. If
it was if it was your mom, if it was your mom, okay, or or some
or you managed to get a woman pregnant and then and then she
squirted out a little
guilded I'm sorry. On this stream, will you say you shouldn't
get emotional and take it personally when it's not your child
that's being asked to produce?
>> Okay. I honestly
when I believe that any kid is being hurt, I'll become as emotional
as if it were my own. >> It's not a child being hurt, is
it? >> Okay. If you're encouraging a kid to sit there and
get and just allow it to happen, then yes. Yes. >> Allow
it to happen. When did this happen? Sorry.
>> Why did that person you do not flee the situation? Stay
there and film it. Stay there and film it. >> That's not
what happened. That's not what happened.
>> I mean, I don't think that's what it doesn't sound like
that's possible. What >> Number one. Number one, uh, as
far as I'm aware, he never he never he never he never actually
spoke to to the kid. Um, that's according to the story I've heard.
The recording of where this is brought up doesn't even have the
kid in the call. Number two. Number three, at also told at no
at no point didn't say
>> then lies never said that he's done this. He says we
as in the people discussing this. >> Okay. So, him and
several others according to him told the kid to >> or somebody
of that group. Sure. >> Can we pull up the clip? >> Who
cares? I pulled up earlier
pulled up. >> It isn't your kid. >> Okay. So if it's
not my kid, I shouldn't be emotional if I believe in >> Godamn
right you shouldn't be emotional. Yeah, god damn right it is
literally >> you're not the internet. Are you a minor?
Is that what it is?
>> This is related to the doxing. It's related to why people
don't like the locomboy guy and Aiden had made this allegation
that loyal comboy told a minor that instead of getting out of
your house,
you should try to film yourself being raped. So basically the
idea was that this child was being raped
and he said actually you should stay and film it instead of getting
out. I don't believe that happened. >> Is that what it
is? Aiden turn a blind eye if it's not your child. Gilded
You can make fun of it but it's not. But getting emotionally
invested in somebody else's kid makes you a freak. That makes
you a weirdo freak. You're emotionally invested in somebody else's
child school. You were too busy to [__] a [__]
freak.
Okay. But yeah, you should I wonder how many 17year-olds
is on your hard drive. How many Why are you so emotionally invested
in somebody else's kids? >> No, I'm asking. No, I didn't.
>> Number two. Number two. More importantly than that,
>> slandering you. You got to address that. >> No,
I actually don't have to address people just straight up lying.
You know, like you you were sitting here pretending that you
were you emotionally you you were you were sitting here pretending
that you gave a about some 17-year-old in a call that by the
way happened last year. You're using a last year call AS PRETEXT
TO JUSTIFY dxing doxing somebody's life that makes you a freak.
You're a you're a moral and you should kill yourself. You should
have to bring it to aid. Shut the up. Shut the [__]
up, dude. Okay. I'm going to just say real quick. I know we're
getting heated. Keep within TS, please. Thank you. Okay, I'll
wait for my OBS to
>> Okay, listen. We disavow that in the strongest Okay.
Okay. We disavow those comments. Strongest possible terms and
something's getting heated.
>> You know what? You know what? You know what? Okay. I
just have a really good >> Yes. Gilded, not my kid, not
my problem. >> If you were if you were justified in all
of that, right? >> I wasn't.
>> You You weren't cuz you were just >> No, no, I
was not justified in in posting. That's what I'm saying sorry
for. But I think that if you're being if you're exempting yourself
under your own logic, you would have to exempt me >> then.
No, I don't.
The entire the entire the entire premise was that it was my kid,
Aiden. It was mine. That's the >> premise. No, that's the
that that's the Okay, that's like the specific detail, right?
But the whole point would be that would be something the relevance
to you doxing would be that would be something that would invoke
enough emotion to make a reasonable person act unreasonably.
>> He went he went after my family.
Yeah, cuz it's my family. Yeah. >> Yes. Okay. Okay. But
if the point is that that's what makes you emotional, okay, and
that emotion led to you, I guess, losing uh losing your judgment
or whatever temporarily, and that's the mitigating excuse for
you, then subjectively I can say yes, other people's kids being
encouraged to do like that makes me emotional. But you
feel your
>> I not only that, I just think you can't do that as somebody
who's who's looking for controversy like this. You're always
going to have somebody who's like getting emotionally within
a situation. You do commentary streams. You're looking for situations
like that. You can't let yourself get emotionally. You're giving
yourself license to be emotionally compromised in every single
>> You waited a year, Aiden. I waited I've I've only known
about this for like >> he's been unreasonable for the last
year. You got to understand.
>> Yeah. You you you you literally heard about that call
at what at least a last year, right? Waited entire months and
Yeah. and then and then waited entire months and then decided
that what you were going to >> Yeah. Yeah. You waited entire
months between Lio's the the threat I perceived at the time and
my video was a matter of mere date
being allowed to get away with this behavior and it's being actively
swept for by people like Beckett who were just saying he misspoke
which is like infinite charity being afforded to this guy. Right.
Um and because of that I viewed him as a threat as well.
You >> you viewed Becket as a threat as well? >> No,
Lio. I view Lio as a threat.
>> Um All right. So, you still kind of threaten
I get very angry and emotional around the subject of Lio. >> Cuz
I don't like even if it's not my kid and his wife. >> Yeah,
that was wrong. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Maybe like your audio wasn't
working. Didn't we already concede that that was wrong?
>> But you're also
>> just real quick. Didn't this guy sweep for Destiny a
lot? Did wasn't this guy like really like he was defending Destiny?
Maybe it was all Maybe it was all a joke. I thought he was kind
of saying people were overreacting about it. It seemed like he
was saying that. >> Last time that you apologized and changed
your take, you castigated me for not asking for the new position.
So what's the new position and what made you change your mind?
>> The new position is that I was overcome
I'm not asking about your mind state in that moment. I'm asking
about the new moral position.
That's a part of my position. That's a that's a part of my >> You
got [__] >> The only reason you would want
details omitted is if you're trying to disingenuously paint a
narrative. Why can't I just >> Well, I'm trying to keep
you focused on what your new position is. >> Well, no.
I promise you this will literally set like two seconds. >> Yeah.
My mindset was that my judge was impaired by uh anger and hatred
for this individual coupled uh with the effects of alcohol and
in your presence on the phone I engaged in behavior against him
against his wife uh that was immoral by my own standards and
by most other people's standards. Um and >> can you explain
the behavior last night
>> Okay. He's trying to take the knee. He's trying to take
the knee. And yeah, this is going to be dickers could >> leaking
the wife easily point out >> Wait, where did I leak her
name last night? Okay, bro. You're getting too big for your boo
>> on my stream. >> I leaked her name on your stream.
Isn't Lio Public about her first name?
>> How do I know then? How would I know what her first
name is,
>> I don't think I I don't think her first name was a leak.
Her last name, her maiden name absolutely was. >> No, her
first name was leak as well. >> Was it? All right. Well,
I I'm just going to I'm just going to do a mass transcript search.
Hold on, Cuz I'm almost certain it is. >> Um Okay. Okay.
What do you What do you mean by it's not? I I'm asking for a
good reason. Sorry. Why is that? What do you mean? >> Has
Lio not voluntarily given people his wife's first name on multiple
occasions in a public Um, not that I'm aware of. No, I I do know.
>> You know how this information was found out in
>> how information was found out? >> How Liario's
wife's information was found out >> on my end. >> Brutal,
man. >> Uh, on your end when you were talking about it
being leaked like years ago. >> Yeah, I just I just typed
in first name Lio Convoy on YouTube and just clicked >> How
did you find out how she where she like what she worked as? >> You
didn't get that from the YouTube
>> What she worked as? I don't think I got that right.
She didn't >> How did you find out her How did you find
out her papers? You didn't get that. You got it from Leo's uniforms
>> Well, yeah. I keep hearing this claim that I was linking
people papers. Have we been presented with substantiation of
>> Nobody's claimed that. >> People were I can I
can literally get you 15 people who will admit that they were
claiming that are like yes earlier. Forgot exactly. >> You
read papers? >> Yes. So what people were claim to be clear
were wrong. Um have I read our papers? Yeah. >> Not not
to my knowledge. No.
>> Okay. Well, you spoke about it. It wasn't a joke. It
was kind of
a joke there. Um and if you see with me and go that was the whole
intention we were going over last night. >> Okay. Which
paper of hers did I read to you? You could DM it to me. I don't
think I've read anything. No, you didn't read out a paper. You
said that you've read papers that she has written. >> Oh,
oh, so I guess >> and you commented that you wanted to
go into a very similar field.
>> Well, no, actually we didn't because then we went down
the whole like uh like >> I've never read any of her address.
I've literally I've explained to you I've never read any of her
papers. If I said it to you, I was intoxicated. But I must have
drunken Nostradamus over here. >> Well, no, cuz like a
way you would prove that I would be lying about this. Like surely
if I read them, like wouldn't I be going over the specifics?
>> I don't know if you'd understand the specifics. You
you don't know >> the general the general I don't know
like the the the focus of her papers.
>> Well, yeah. You know that you know the area that she's
in cuz you commented you want to go in a very similar area about
Okay. So, you know the area that she's publishing in. >> Well,
yeah. Okay. Okay. In a >> Okay. So, you have the area.
You've read the paper. >> I say like okay sometime I say
like okay sometimes even if like that's not like I don't know.
Let's just >> We're catching up so it's got to be a little
fast right now. But we got to catch up. >> I haven't read
any of her papers. No.
>> Okay. Drop the snark. >> Have you read low kiwi
farms page? I just don't know how you know what she does for
work if you
that's not on that YouTube because farms. No. And this is going
to surprise people cuz I probably should have. Kiwi Farms is
at least not to No, I don't think I ever have because Kiwi Farms
was like totally unreadable. >> You lied it cuz you said
this to me IRL when you were at the bar with me. >> You
were at the bar and you stated I Aiden have read Lio Convoy's
Kiwi Farm. >> Here's a better question. How did you know
that her photos were from her Facebook?
Cuz that I'm pretty sure that's what I was told. >> By
who? I don't know. Were they from her >> I I actually don't
remember.
>> they were. How do you know they're from her Facebook?
>> Cuz I've read Lyon Boy's Kiwi Farms page to find where
you find this information >> I don't read his Kiwi Farms
page. >> Yes, you were reading it while you were at the
bar with us. I never [__] read it. I get the employee
cuz I was saying that that night when I was you not scrolling
through Kiwi Farms
Queen Hellbent.
I'm not saying I'm asking you the question. Were you scrolling
through Kiwi forms? >> No, I've never I've never Wait,
is there a way I don't clear my search history? I don't clear
my search history. Are you clear on >> You were scrolling.
I saw you scrolling through Kiwi forms cuz I saw the UI and you
I asked you, are you reading through Kiwi Farms page right now
and you said >> my search history? Wait, so then we can
pro I can prove that you're lying. Let me Hey, what was the date
and time?
>> We went to went to the bar. >> Yeah, I I I'll
literally show you my search history on that date and time.
>> It's a weird thing to lie about. I know. It's a weird
thing to talk about, especially in the context that I was apparently
wasn't even apparently hellbent wasn't even there. I don't know
if I
bar at >> which was out with all of them. >> Do you
remember that? >> The No, we went to a club and went to
a bar. I said the first bar we're at. >> Okay. So, what
time would that have >> When did we meet up? It was around
and just post it for the day. >> Yeah. Because if I don't
clear if I don't clear my search history, this should be easily
feudable, right? Um, let's figure it out. Let's look at our DMs.
And then if when like if I give you my search history now, right,
you'll like uh you'll omit anything that's not relevant to this
subject, right? >> Well, no, because I I'll still know
that you've read through a kiwi bombs. Like there's other corroborating
information. >> He's literally saying this is his first.
>> If I can show you some some logs that say I didn't look.
That'll make you forget what you saw, right? In the conversation
we had. Yeah. Uh yeah, >> See it? >> That makes sense.
So, what's the time I'm looking up? Um I don't know, bro. Just
look at the day.
Did he die? Anyway, just posted the day. I was [__]
muted. Apologies. >> To give you my search history, apparently
now, apparently now,
um, this actually wouldn't even be good enough. So, just to be
clear, your claim is it's unfalsifiable.
There is no burnout. >> What are you talking about?
>> So, okay. Do you think that if I if I was to present
you my search history, would that be adequate enough for you
to admit that I was actually not >> You've never read her
Kiwi Farms page? Obviously not. No, >> he has a Kiwi Farms
page. >> Oh, I misspoke. He >> Oh god. No, that is
a misspoke. If I did If I did that, it would be like I'm
such a >> I have a question. But I have a I have a question
real quick. So, okay. So, let me let me see if I can steal man
your position about the uh about the >> Okay, no, we're
going to go back into this. How did you know the the the um how
did you know what you did for work, Aiden? I
don't I honestly I don't know. I don't remember. But it certainly
wasn't through a Kiwi Farms. Better yet, why don't I why don't
we get like 6 months worth of search history if cuz this would
be somewhere I'd frequent, right?
If I just happen to pull it up at that exact time if you think
I can delete it. >> I I've looked I I don't know if you
realize this. I found the YouTube page that you use to like find
out her
>> Right. So, I found the YouTube page that you you searched
for,
and I know what information it does have and doesn't have, and
it doesn't have any of her work information on that. >> That
is only there on her Kiwi Farms
>> I wasn't Look >> I don't know why. Okay.
>> I don't look at I don't look at his Kiwi Farms thread
>> and then you can't remember how you know this information
to tell you. Wait, hold on. If you're indic
Why would I Why would I be this dickers? This makes no sense.
This like whole like you're trying to I don't know construct
like some complete like lie, but this makes no sense because
why would I be comfortable admitting to utilizing the information
I got from this YouTube channel but not the information I got
from Kiwi Farms when
the same moral connotation? >> I've I've said they've got
you you use them both.
>> Yeah, but why am I only comfortable admitting to one?
>> I don't know. That's what I'm confused >> Maybe
maybe because you know this extra information. it just like you
misremembered that Hellbent was >> I haven't misremembered
it. Waited
any part of this Hellbent was not Hellbent Hellbent didn't get
to the bar until
>> Oh my god, dude. I'm talking and trying to remind you
about the particular bar that we went to.
>> Yeah, the the one we went >> I wasn't saying that
Hellbent was there at the time. >> you wait. You understand?
Okay, so we went out that night. I think I got there
>> It's just the Tom Foolery spiral. Like literally, no.
Aiden is misunderstanding and thinking that this is like a subjective
thing that he can argue. Dickers is saying, "I watched you scroll
the page. I watched you read it. Other people at the table were
there. You are lying. Like I'm not having the argument. You are
trying to argue something that is inarguable. I understand that
you're like a debate lord. You can debate anything. Stop arguing.
You're wrong." Like literally everybody around you is just saying,
"Stop arguing. You're >> What? Like the the event opens
at like what? 7:30, 8:00 p.m. So I get there with I was with
Perry and Queen. I don't know what time you showed up. >> I
mean, okay, we're going by other people's recollection now. >> Show
up the night. He didn't say that until the very end.
>> So it seems like I wasn't claiming that Hellbent was
there at the time. I was trying to recall I was trying to help
you recall what Barbie >> It sounds like you were trying
to like add like some like backing to your claim. There were
other witnesses there or whatever, but I she >> I never
claimed that anybody else heard >> Okay. So, you were the
only one. >> I thought he was claiming I thought he was
claiming >> No, you saw it as well. He's on your phone,
bro. >> Yeah. And I'm telling So, we have two people. We
have one saying it happened. I'm telling you that is a complete
lie and I'm totally willing if you're willing to agree. >> So,
I completely invented this in my mind. I just >> unironically
just like how until we had go to say that the private call happened.
You had no idea what the private call was. Absolutely no clue
at all. Was this a public? I guess it somewhere I don't remember
why is Lia's Kiwi Farms like why wouldn't that be in the last
6 months of my search history like the I'm the evidence just
wouldn't support anything you're saying
>> I don't know detailed
this is contentious
proves your entire point just so we're being forthcoming about
this your claim is that despite me being okay at conceding and
admitting I was wrong with the YouTube with the information that
I pulled off spread from this YouTube channel. Despite being
totally okay, conceding, admitting, apologizing for this, I'm
not okay with admitting and conceding that I pulled information
off Kiwi Farms and you're backing proof for this partially is
that you witnessed me at a bar scrolling through Kiwi Farms and
the only way for me to disprove this pulling up my search history
is apparently not like a burden that I I guess anyone is like
excited about. >> So, there's several things here, right?
There's several things here. >> What's the >> I've
seen URL scrolling through and reading Lio's Kiwi Farm's page
while we're at the bar. So, that's one. Second thing is that
the information that we're >> Hold on. The second thing
is the information that you're talking about can't be found on
that YouTube channel that you've used for this. I've looked into
it. >> Dude, could you imagine how awesome it would be
if Dickers is just lying right here? No. Calculated that he can
just lie about this and nobody will believe Aiden ever. So he
can just lie about it. He can't just make it up. He can't just
with Aiden
on the phone. Now you're saying there's somebody else. You're
saying that somebody and it's disingenuous to act disingenuous
to act. These are these are published papers
saying there. So what I'm saying is you're claiming that somebody
has told you this at some point what she did for work. I'm asking
who when do you do you often talk
liars like occupation?
>> Okay. So just to be clear just to be clear I've been
covering this guy for I I've spoken to every likely
Yeah. I of course I'm I hate him. I don't I typically I I don't
like people who's done the the horrible things he's done which
you can't >> horrible. Oh >> you shouldn't be you
shouldn't be encouraging other people to film themselves
and off to how good of a person I am. >> You know I'm not
right. There's >> you can
such a good person. You're such a hero. Yeah. Go on. >> I
can hate somebody without saying that I'm a good person. >> I
don't know how to explain this any better than this. I'll just
explain it here. If Dickers were lying and Aiden was 100% correct
that this Kiwi Farms thing is totally made up and Dickers were
just lying. Aiden still loses. There's no reason to be here doing
this. Aiden loses automatically, but he can't detect it. It's
like totally out of his >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. You're a hero.
Go on. Sorry. Go on. >> Yeah. Nobody's saying that except
you. I don't know if you're like schizophrenic.
>> The question I wanted to ask if we're just going to
get distracted on this. Okay. Hayden, are you saying that every
time that you see somebody in a drama that you get particularly
annoyed about, it's possible that you might dox them? If you
see somebody who's abused a child, you get so emotionally connected,
you get so emotionally connected by covering obsessively. Wait,
wait. Stickers, stickers, stickers. You understand? That wasn't
that wasn't that wasn't my thought. That wasn't my full thought
cuz you could actually hear me on this VOD and get interrupted
midway through, right? Causing. So, if you want to finish the
statement so you can then derive a conclusion from the statement
in full, feel free, but it's a little disingenuous to try to
derive conclusions from verifiably pointless >> a question.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, let me So, can I just like finish if
that's okay? >> You absolutely can. Please go ahead. >> Yeah.
Thank you so much. Really appreciate that. Um, so as I was saying,
right, I've covered this guy over this. >> Sorry, we're
just catching up on buffering multiple months speaking to several
people who who have hated him for years. Several details about
various I don't even know what have been given to me. I've sorted
through I've sorted through information not through Kiwi Farms.
I've sort through information that I've been given secondhand,
etc., etc. It is not necessarily indicative of dishonesty for
me not being able to remember the specific source of a by virtue
of the amount of information in processing uh this drama in regards
to the extent of my involvement which other people admit is obsessive.
It's not necessarily suspicious that I can't recall the exact
source for I derived this hyper specific piece of information.
What? How many people have you been trying to source liar convoy's
wife's information from? You can't remember who's gave it to
you. >> Yeah, because that's like one, as I've explained
before, this is like months worth. This is like a lot of information
aggregation. So, no. >> No, I'm asking the number of people
like how many people >> Dickers needs to say. Okay. So,
you give permission for whoever did send this to you to to like
put that information out, right? You give them >> sourcing
Lio Convoy's wife's information from you can't remember who gave
you this piece of information >> to quantify. Let's just
recall out of the out of like 50 people like how many mention
you got? >> No, that was hyperbole.
I'm asking you park information
is who how many people have you been sourcing liar convoy's wife's
information from? >> I don't I don't know who I was given
this. I just know where it wasn't from. >> Not who not
who how many people? >> I don't know the number. If he
can't remember
that on the spot, a lot of people can't remember.
I'd have to go through like I'd have to go through months worth
of coverage. >> My question is why wouldn't you get rid
of them after they did that? >> Get rid of who? >> Whoever
gave you information on his wife. Like >> all the detractors
that have called in to give me about I don't talk to even Beanskys
who I think Lio is wronging. I removed Beanskis from my server
cuz all these people are freaks themselves and I don't like keeping
them around. So, >> so,
so, okay, so hypothetically, if somebody that, let's say, wasn't
a freak, okay, that was a was a member of your community, wasn't
a freak, went on Kiwi Farms, gave you all the relevant information
in addition to what you found on YouTube.
Uh, would you get rid of that person for giving you that information?
Would you be upset with that person?
>> I would tell them off for it, but if they It depends
on if they gave it to me privately versus public >> That's
what I mean. I mean, private I mean privately. I mean privately.
Oh, if they did it privately, I I'd correct the behavior because
I think that's publicly disseminating this information.
>> You'd tell them off. >> Oh, yeah. If they were
doing that Yes. >> This is the This is the whole thing
is Aiden's performing. I've been sent information that's like
that's like maybe like realistically if somebody's posting that
publicly, I'd be upset. I've received information like that.
You don't tell them off. You just go obviously this needs to
remain private. You handle it like as appropriate. Just saying,
"Oh, no. If anybody ever sent me something inappropriate, I'd
tell them off immediately. Like, you're just lying. You're just
lying to save face in the moment. It's just obvious. >> Told
people. >> You've You've answered before you actually have
tried to think about it at >> I've told people off for
go for what I've perceived as going too far trying to get >> Would
you tell people off if you if somebody showed you somebody's
face in
>> Would I tell them off?
>> Yeah. Somebody shared information with >> To be
honest with you, if it's a face, I very well might not. If it's
just like a face talks, >> wait a minute. Then why do you
Then why do you care about my video? >> I only care about
your video cuz to prove that like you're a hypocrite. >> No,
you brought it No, you brought it up in the first place. Like
it was
Yeah, cuz I think you're a hypocrite. >> How am I a hypocrite
for a face stocks you don't care about? >> Because I think
because I because Okay, so you're getting on me. You're getting
on me for this, right? >> I'm not getting on you for for
explicitly the face stocks. If all you did was post a picture
of her face and that was it, I actually just wouldn't care either
for the record. >> So I I said her name in VC in addition
to posting her face. I met up. >> Yes, that that the issue
I took wasn't the face docks. It was the name and her
>> and one more thing. I'm sorry. So, what have I said
so far? That's wrong cuz apparently I've like
conversation. >> Okay. Okay. Let me let me put this another
way for you to Okay. Are you reading chat right now? Just [__]
leave it off, bro. >> Well, no. I I there's like all these
like all these like posturing comments like just one more debate.
You're correct. Like I feel like I've been like relatively receptive
to everything that's said. I've directly addressed people's arguments.
I think I've been like reasonable in the logic that I've provided
uh in proving Gilded's
>> Can I I want I want to ask you if I want to ask you
a question. >> It's like I'm being serious here. Okay.
>> And you haven't even proven You haven't even proven
logically THAT I'M CRASHING OUT. YOU HAVEN'T EVEN PROVEN IT.
HOW COULD YOU SAY IT IN THE CHAT? HOW COULD YOU SAY IT? SO, UM,
you said you were upset with Liao for how he treats people, namely
the 17-year-old, cited, uh, him apparently posing an idea of
recording herself being groped in her sleep as one of your reasons
for why you find him disgusting and that that was a factor in
why you decided it was a good idea to drop information on wife.
Correct. Is that all fair assess?
>> No, I'm saying under your logic that would create the
same level of emotional contribution when judgment asking you
just just yes or no. >> Yeah, I'm responding. I'm explain.
Okay. The only way with a question like that you would want to
boil it down to yes or no is if you're purposefully attempting
to be dishonest and spend
this question.
>> Dude, Aiden is debating so hard.
This be a question that requires elaboration and nuance and to
want to avoid that elaboration and nuance would only be done
if you were attempting to be dishonest because additional
you're going to like what Aiden is saying is very simply that
he he can provide an emotional reason if asked why he would take
that path. But he's also saying he doesn't actually have that
emotional reason. He was wrong to release the information. He
did it cuz he was drunk and
Yeah, that's fair. Yeah. >> Okay. Right. Okay. >> Oh,
wow. That's that's all you had to say. Okay. Cool. >> So,
um uh the reason I asked all of that and that that being whatever
answer, so my the reason I asked all of that is because in my
particular case, the entire reason I did what I did was in direct
response to a threat, a direct threat at me and mine.
>> Okay. So, I'm somebody with >> like But hold on.
That is different from the example you posed, which was more
akin to vengeance, implying that I was doing it out of revenge
as opposed to a response to a threat. >> Wait, how? Okay.
Okay. If you were addressing a threat, how did you leaking photos
of Li's wife address the threat against kids? >> To end
the threat.
>> Oh, okay. So if I said because Lio is continues to verifiably
threaten people if I want to scare him off the internet so he
stops doing what he's doing >> and other people you or
yours if you like your mom. >> So So you're somebody So
you're somebody that like >> can't understand like empathy
for other human beings unless you're blood related to them. For
me personally >> dude I I'm sorry. I am not gonna sit there
and watch paid programming of starving kids in >> said
empathy. I'm not
I'm not going to I'm not gonna sit there and actually pretend
like I give a >> So cool that you hate empathy. I don't
give a about your kids. I don't care about your kids. >> Cool.
Good for you. >> I don't care about your kids. Like
>> No, I'm not. >> Not my kids. Not my kids, bro.
I have been very consistent on this. In fact, there's entire
video where I say, "Not my kid, not my problem. You pay me."
Okay? So, no, I'm not going to sit there and emotionally moral
over kids that aren't mine. That's just like that's and I think
that's completely fair cuz they're not my kids.
And furthermore, it doesn't matter anyway because the point was
to end a threat that was done to my kid, to my family. That is
different from what you're describing. >> Okay. I want
to end threats against people like Bonnie Chan. Uh I have empathy
for these human beings and I want to end the threats against
them. >> Sorry, can you repeat that?
>> Yeah, I I want to end the threats against people like
Bonnie Chan. Uh I want to I believe that Lia's continuous comments
to Beanskis uh clearly are trying to urge this person to take
his own life. Uh and this guy is verifiably uh attempted to take
his own life. So I think he's a threat to >> Beanskis.
I mean, but but but here's the thing though. You did that months
later, right? Like >> months of the Beansky stuff
guild of the Beansky stuff is ongoing.
>> Oh, so you Okay, so you did this because of the Beansky
stuff then.
I just want to take two seconds
because that's not what you did. >> I want to see nothing
is actually gay. Hugely appreciate it. Thank you. No, >> my
point is like, yeah, Lio is somebody that like I have hatred
for. He does induce emotion. That emotion obviously affected
my judgment to some
emotion apparently acts as like a you know minimizing factor
I think that that would also be applicable here
when you did the same thing that I did it has nothing to do with
emotion has nothing to do with emotion and it wasn't worse I
never dropped her name I never mentioned what she did for a living
I never attached I never attached a name to her face it never
happened >> you did this you did this you did this
Hello. I'm sorry. I shouldn't mute. I should pause one second.
Roz, thank you for the two gifted. Let's go.
>> Okay,
this was in a This was >> Okay, this is This is like the
difference between uh a drug dealer giving kids heroin and a
drug dealer saying, "I didn't give the kid heroin. I gave the
heroin to another dealer that >> drug a drug dealer that
gives like five kids heroin versus a drug dealer that gives like
that gives like thousand kids." No, no, no. The point is you
distributed the content way more content than I ever distributed
to people who would be willing. It was just a name and the images
you gave, by the way, can be could have been input into any reverse
uh image software like PMI or face. >> You made it easier.
>> You made it easier. You shouldn't have given the public.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And you shouldn't have given
you the public.
>> You've had to shut down Icy Chat today because so many
people are leaving. >> I never shut down a constant problem
with chat. Someone else has already. Have you not redacted Icy
Chat? >> No, somebody [__] No, no, somebody
else did. Okay. And they literally admitted publicly.
>> Are leaks a problem with Icy Chat? >> Is it a
constant source of drama? The amount of people who leak Icy Chat.
>> It's a constant source of drama. I wouldn't say constant.
It's like it's like discouraged.
>> No, no, no. But it's like there are there are frequent
leaks from people trying to hunt down who is leaked from >> Just
to be clear. Just to be clear, you would have to believe that
I'm paying someone off to take the fall for me right now. What
the [__] And multiple witnesses backing them when
they admit that they were the ones that did it. If you believe
that
no, people are acting like what I've just said was like a lie.
It's not. It's someone is >> Okay, you're talking to me,
Eden. You're talking to me right now. >> You can say you
can say that
obviously. So, it's going to be impossible to have this conversation.
This is Paulo all over again
to have this conversation if you're at the same time trying to
argue with chat. >> I've addressed chatters like three
>> He's debate his own. >> It's been It's been three
It's literally been three times. Okay, but it completely derails.
>> Dude, come on, man. >> Conversation every time
you do. So, I'm asking you to >> It's impossible to have
this conversation whenever you What I was saying is that it's
a constant source of leaks in chat. The idea >> Hold on.
We're going to We're going to fix this right now. Last It's over.
It's over. Won't happen again. Maybe.
>> Dude, am I having >> to expect that Icy Chat is
going to be like a private server that people aren't going to
leak from is ridiculous.
>> Generally speaking, tons of things, >> Yeah. Tons
of things that don't matter don't get leaked. Well, things that
also matter have not been leaked. Leaks are not like a constant
issue. No, >> I'm sorry. But leaks are leaks areable. >> Dickers,
you downloaded all the mod logs. So, why don't you show us how
many >> Guys, it was okay because you can't, you >> Yeah,
you prove to me that I downloaded all the Can you prove download?
>> Okay. Sorry, we're catching up again. Now we're caught
up. >> Can you prove that? Can I Can you prove that I downloaded
all the mods? Oh, so you just lied. >> Wait, didn't you
literally you did? Can you Can you prove that? Have you got >> So
you're So on the record, you're denying you ever said that.
>> Well, no, I'm asking I'm asking, can you prove that?
I don't remember saying >> No, that's why I'm asking you.
Did you do that?
>> I don't remember. I don't remember. Have you got Have
you got proof of that? >> So, you don't remember doing
that? >> You got >> I don't remember doing that.
Can you Can you prove that I said that? >> Have you been
intoxicated in the last 24
>> You haven't? Okay. And this would have occurred within
the last 24 hours per the allegation. So it would be >> I'm
asking if you've got a I'm asking if you've got a clip of me
saying that. >> Bring it up as in my case I've forgotten
something. Um it's actually totally >> I'm saying so you
just like completely made that up then. >> So you conceding
you just completely made that up. Okay. Have you got proof >> I
said that? >> I don't remember ever saying that. Have you
got proof that I said that?
>> You know what? I guess I don't. So Dickers is denying
that he said it. Um and when we get proof that you'll admit you
lied right again for the second
>> I will admit that I lied if you can find it. Yeah, sure.
So what I said was
>> was the pool pot fellow. This is Gilded Pooh. Somebody
who's made a I think he made a video hit piece on Queen actually.
Um but Aiden's accusing him of like doxing Leo Convoy's wife.
He did a video where I think apparently a picture of her was
in there or something. Okay. Cuz this guy thought Leo Convoy
like threatened his kid. Okay. So Aiden's like, "Oh, this saves
me somehow." Aiden can't about his criticisms away. That can't
happen anymore. I don't know why he's trying to. It will show
it's more of a mockery that I got you anyway. So what I'm talking
about what I'm talking about what I'm talking about when cuz
you denied stuff like right. So you're selecting with what you
with what you deny. It's cuz what you don't expect to have uh
evidence for. I don't expect you're going to have evidence for
me saying that I've downloaded all the mods cuz I haven't downloaded
all the mods. I've screenshotted me deleting the >> Okay.
So we're going to So Okay. So do you want access to all the mod
logs? I can give that to you so you can actually quantify and
say leaks happen all the time. Surely you'll be able to quantify
that with the mod the mod logs in total >> What are you
talking about? You brought up me like downloading mod logs or
>> Okay. Okay. Apparently I guess I got the factoid wrong.
I guess you didn't. I >> I'm just asking why did you bring
this up? What's what's the relevance?
>> Well, no. Because you're making the claim that leaks
happen all the time. Mod logs would be a way for you to be able
to determine that. >> How would that how would that how
would that talk about violations and banning people when leaks
do occur occasionally when you're able to prove who has leaked
>> So it would help you quantify your statement. made a
statement all the time, right? >> They're monitoring all
I said it's it's I said it's leaks happen
that there is leaked from Icyhat. >> Are you are you actually
just like not able to understand the relevance? >> The
leaks are just >> No. Anytime there's >> you deny
that leaks frequently happen from Icy chat. Yes or no? >> Frequently.
Uh no. Relative to the amount of information >> as in they
happen regularly as it's not like incidental. Everyone's super
shocked
like Yeah. Occasionally like every so often. Yeah. >> Yeah.
And the mod logs can like easily substantiate that, right? And
I can give them to you right now. You can go through them if
you'd like. >> I don't know what your disapprov
But but okay. Why when leaks have happened, why do we talk about
it in mod logs sometimes but not others?
>> Wait, you talk about it in mod logs >> or in the
modhat? Sorry, logs of the mod chat, I should say.
>> I figured out why we were buffering. We're good. >> What?
Fixed. >> That very rarely gets discussed in you like to
do this. You like to make claims where we just have to completely
trust your word >> for it to be true. I'm giving you a
source that will help you something >> It happens with
some frequency. Yes. >> I mean frequently. So I will give
you access to the full logs to prove that because I'm telling
you that you are liable. It >> is not a it is not a black
swan event for Icy to get leaked. >> That's all I'm saying.
It happens with some frequency. >> So So since you're making
the claim, I'm open book. I'll give you the evidence right now
and you can prove it and demonstrate it to us. You've already
accepted that it happens. >> No, I haven't. I said occasionally
like 5 seconds ago. That's another lie. >> Occasionally
happens. >> That's another lie. Nobody's accepted
>> How the
you posted information
in an area which you know is vaguely public with multiple people
in where you have experienced occasional leaks. You know it's
not >> leaks. Leak. Okay. Leaks every so often is is hardly
public. Okay. That's just not like 100 people.
I actually want to join. Stop entertaining. >> Just stop
entertaining the absurd idea that 100 person group chat is private.
Stop entertaining it. Tell him to shut the up. You're not talking
about it anymore. If he wants to talk about it, he can go to
Icy Chat and whine about it. It is a public chat. Shut the [__]
up about it. Holy [__] Stop calling it >> I'm
going to go to Walmart and
Walmart in front of aundred people. And since only 15 of them
actually told someone else, it's fine. >> Ticker, sorry.
Sorry, Beck. If somebody's like if somebody lives in a bad neighborhood,
their their home's been like burglarized a few times in 15 years
of living there, is it is it basically public property? >> You
got it.
>> You're talking Let's just not talk just about Icy chat.
Let's just talk about Discords generally. You are talking about
a public discord. That is your discord. You have a chat where
the I believe the like conditions for entry are recommendation
and like you've got to be in for a week. That's that's basically
it for Icy, right? >> Recommendation. You have to be in
for a week and I have to No, it's literally just I have to personally
approve you. There's no time limit. >> So So okay, so you
have to personally approve somebody. So any chatter could randomly
be nice to you, get approved for this chat within your public
Discord, and then be able to see everything in it. Correct. >> No,
not necessarily. Not just being nice. Um >> Okay. Not just
being nice, but >> I I have to I have to reasonably trust
that you're just not going to be >> No, you don't. Aiden,
you added a guy cuz you found his tweets funny. >> Yeah,
but I also reasonably So like I go through So you go through
Okay. So you go through like people he's associated with and
his involvement with drama and you understand. Okay. This isn't
somebody that's like anywhere
in people.
>> So So just to be clear,
just to be clear, your reputation is irrelevant. It didn't It
didn't What's the Twitter name anyway? cuz you're accepting that
this is a bad thing to do, right? This was like the the incorrect
action to take >> Yeah. So, I don't know why Dickers is
just like lying that leaks are frequent when I've already conceived.
>> Oh my god.
>> No, it is a lie. I can literally quantify for you. I
think like
you keep getting caught up on these tiny minut
you you're making yourself look. >> Just stop lying. Like
is that is that like that hard to app?
>> Do you know how many people from your server like leak
to me and other people all the time every day? >> Can you
give us a specific number?
>> You got >> No, I can't. It's a lot. >> You
can? Oh, but I thought I thought it's suspicious if you can't
give specific numbers about like vague occurrences on the spot.
>> I never I never said that. >> You didn't. I was
referring to Dickers. Dickers, do you find that suspicious on
Gilded Pooone? What the
>> what do you mean? What the [__] Drawing
a parallel to
100 member YouTube channel or Discord channel is private
>> at that point. You've got that many people in there.
You're not adding people that you trust. You're adding a guy
cuz you find his tweets funny. You saw this guy write on November
15th, 2025 up late getting and it made you laugh so much you
added him to to Icy >> because I didn't think he was a
leak risk. They he saw the message. Thank god it is never leaked.
>> You're running in random people cuz you find them funny,
which is fine. Which is totally fine. Okay. But the problem is
none of this information is private. It's just not a public
in that. >> The idea that you can keep a 100 member channel
reasonably private. Even reasonably private is like completely
deranged. It's not a teeny tiny group.
already agreed
on some occasion. >> That's another lie because I've already
said to you it's like every
the actual the evidence counteracts it. Why then have I seen
every
message this
I'm going to I'm going to violate to us.
frog has sent in this chat. I'VE SEEN EVERY MESSAGE HE SENT FOR
THE PAST two
I see he's actually private. No, I've seen every single message
you've sent. I've also seen everybody reacting to you doxing
this woman >> occasionally. Yes.
>> I don't know why you're in here.
>> Leaks happen. Yes or no?
>> Leaks happen. Yes or no? >> Occasionally. Yeah.
Every so often. >> Yeah. Okay, cool. It's not a private
>> Leaks are like a common leaks happen like literally
every like prong group chat like I think consistently. Yeah,
leaks happen occasionally. >> It happens with even more
frequency with 100 people in there. >> Rarely actually
rarely. And now it's
rarely occasionally
mutually exclusive. >> Well, leaks happen to Twitter rarely
because then you'd be you'd be aware of them, right? We got no
idea how often leaks happen in people's DMs. There were >> So
So now I noticed you're now going to the pool of leaks that we
actually are completely unverifiable and therefore unfalsifiable.
I can give you mod logs right now when leaks are something that
we can actually quantify. You don't like using objective evidence.
You don't like >> No, cuz I know cuz I've read the mod
chat that leaks very infrequently get talked about in that, you
know. Okay. So, yes or no. The vast majority of leaks that you
notice and cry about and complain about never get mentioned in
log in mod chat. >> Mod chat is usually used for like when
people are talking about doc's information and it needs that
a conversation needs to happen privately about moderation. >> Was
the claim that leaks get mentioned in mod in Icy chat?
>> Okay, just to be clear
about we don't talk about leaks in mod chat. No.
You didn't claim that?
>> Okay. So, we So, when leaks happen, we do talk about
them in mod chat.
>> Are we talking about only leaks like that are made public?
By the way, is that what we're talking about? >> Yeah.
Aiden's talking about when somebody leaks onto Twitter and then
people go
from you're using you're using unknown known as your like frame
of reference and that's uniable
completely irrelevant to this argument because that could be
applied
100 people are in there no 100 people are in there a lot of these
people it's not a personal friends of yours they're discord members
>> you understand that this is going to is likely going
to get leaked information put into chat is liable to getting
leaked. Yes or no? It's foreseeable that it gets leaked. >> Yeah.
Like like information in every
>> Like was your point that there's a potential for leaks.
That was your point the whole time >> that it's foreseeable
that information you put in there is going to get shared. Yes.
Absolutely. >> No. For people that it is no considering
information is uh leaked rarely, right? Based on what we can
based on like based on an objective measure >> of people
saying the
Sure. Yeah. They're leaked infrequently onto Twitter. Sure. >> Well,
that's that that was I know. I'm saying leaks like period. I
don't know why you're specifying it to sluries. >> I mean,
let's never let's never mind that we know that at least what
like two people have downloaded this image onto their phone if
we're talking about the face dogs for example.
>> Okay. But the claim is >> how many people heard
you say and then write that in chat as well. >> So, who's
leaked? So, who's leaked? I just want to be clear. >> Okay.
Hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on. cuz I'm getting like DMs
from people saying please God like stop this spiraling. So I'm
gonna say >> where is this spiral >> because like
okay it doesn't matter. The core point is this. This was not
like a private group chat or something. You posted that information
in a chat with over like 100 people in it. You knew there was
a risk risk of leaks. That's kind of the core essence here. like
debate borrowing the point those are my DM how much you trust
people or whatever doesn't [__] then don't make the
claim that leaks are >> freaking no here's no here's the
better part if if if it r if there's rarely any leaks okay and
you posted that in there then why did you delete it >> I
didn't delete Dickers deleted it >> are you okay with him
>> we've already spoken about that
>> I deleted my new post to be clear I a couple other people
on the record I didn't delete message in relation to this situation.
>> Okay. Okay. Okay. So I'll give you logs to prove that
if you want to
I'll >> No, you never cleaned it up. No. >> So So
my my question is then why would you apologize then you then
that means by by that standard you did nothing wrong then >> because
by the time I realized it was wrong there was nothing left to
delete. >> When did you when did you realize it was
>> Uh probably
when I sobered up. Maybe like probably the next day. >> So
you came and had a longer >> You've been arguing about
this. Yeah. Dickers
arguing about this even even earlier at like 9 p.m. UK time.
9 hours ago 9 hours ago. You were still defending this. >> To
be clear, just so we're all being clear right now, the criticism
that I agree was accurate and valid. Not to be >> co- occurred
co- occurred with criticism against me that was clearly like
a witch hunt and a dog pile and people people going through my
bathroom. >> Chill the [__] out.
None of this none of the stuff is looped in to you getting criticism
for leaking
base occupence
for us to continue. I don't want anything I say to be like mischaracterized.
And for that to happen, you can't cut the sense off when there's
like additional context. >> Why is it wrong if it was private?
>> Why is Wait, why is what wrong? >> Why was what
you did wrong posted
>> Let Aiden just finish what he was about to say about
people going through his >> this is >> Hold on. Hold
on. This ace space guy, that's not the original person that the
go cat girl dated, is it? Who's donating to Dickers right now?
Dude, what? very >> Yeah. So, I'm saying I'm saying the
general vibe
super defensive and unreceptive to actual valid criticism at
the time which >> Aiden really is like holy [__]
I didn't even realize everybody's uniting against Aiden. Okay.
The the joke from this morning that Chud threw in Spicy Chat
is both the allies and the USSR are closing in right now. Aiden's
looking over at that Luger loggingly. Okay. like you
my generally defensive I felt like I was getting people were
going at me for things at once as you know well before I posted
the face there's been like >> there's been a lot of like
people coming at me over various over this like last week right
so I was >> it spirals out of the queen >> so I was
defensive I was incred I was incredibly defensive and I shouldn't
have been okay that was a shortcoming on my end there are people
talking about like speculating on like who I'm in a relationship
with and now causing trouble in like those areas. Um I have like
pe somebody who like said like and it was stupid. Somebody I
was drinking with who once again won my trust and like I was
just hanging out with uh is now like admitting to like he was
like going through my bathroom and [__] and like
it's just like >> yeah like I'm a little bit like defensive
on >> or you left the concealer out. you released private
information >> on someone's wife while you were drunk and
angry and have not like and and should like the first thing you
should do is apologize for this just take the you don't you don't
have any issues with my criticisms of you there and the fact
that I hadn't gone to the bathroom when he released the >> you
are getting too emotionally involved in this liio and you're
going to up and I've said that >> oh just to be just to
be clear yeah so everything you just said 150% agree except for
the M part cuz the insinuation the M part I think every other
part of my coverage of LEO, it all like still stands. >> Okay.
So,
with your coverage of LIO, I think there I don't want to like
debate, bro. Like, of especially cuz a lot of it's to do >> No,
no, no. I'd agree with you on >> Becky, before you move
on to this, okay, >> cuz I I tried to ask Aiden a question
at the start of the conversation and then Aiden, I guess we never
got round to it. It got lost in the lost in the mix. What's your
stance now? And then why did you change your stance?
Because you asked me when we had a conversation yesterday, why
didn't I ask you why you changed it? And so now I think it's
only fair for me to ask you what's your stance now and why did
you change it? Cuz you were arguing this 9 hours ago. >> Okay,
hold on. Before Aiden goes, I'm just going to say I will um I'm
in Dick's Discord now. I will join if there's something I can
add that's unique or valuable, but otherwise I can just DM people.
I'm not going to jam up the content, right, by joining. I don't
need to do that. They've got it covered. If I DM If I DM them
like something I want asked and they ask it, it's fine. >> Just
so real, Lio didn't encourage someone's kid to like film CS.
>> No, no, I'm asking about your stance on wife's wife.
Lio's wife didn't do this and didn't deserve any of the like
emotional response that came with it and I spread her I spread
her like previously doxed information um in my chat and that
was wrong. >> What's your definition of doxing now? Because
apparently you've been on the definition you gave yesterday.
You claimed you've had this definition for what months? Like
six months. What's your definition of doxing now? >> No,
it's I said I spread her I've spread her docks. >> No,
no. What's your definition of doxing >> Yeah. So, when
you're taking when you're taking somebody's personally identifying
information with malicious intent, which I had, right? And I
had malicious when you're taking somebody's personally identifiable
and establishing a link between that and an anonymous online
persona. Right. So, somebody >> She doesn't have an anonymous
online persona. That was the contention. >> I don't know.
I admit I'm wrong. >> No, no. I'm asking what your stance
is
>> What's your definition of that's I just gave you my
definition. >> But you don't have an anonymous She doesn't
have an anonymous online >> Yeah. Whether or not I personally
characterize that as that's like it's the same amount of harm,
right? I don't think that that like technically falls under the
definition that I've accepted, right? But I can but I think it's
like basically the same thing. So I don't like necessarily object
if you also want to consider that doxing. Um, I still think regardless,
I mean, spreading docks is wrong and does the same thing as if
you yourself were the one that had initially docked somebody.
So, I think that that was wrong to contribute to
>> Okay. Despite the fact that it still doesn't meet your
definition.
>> Why is that? I don't understand that >> cuz then
you're using the word in the sentence, but it seems like you're
using it and saying you don't agree with the definition in that.
>> Sorry. He's his definition has changed back to the actual
definition he had. So, he always thought the Willie stuff was
bad. He did follow the Willie stuff, right? He always thought
that was bad. Even amplifying stuff was bad. >> We're using
it descriptively as you just laid out the No, I'm saying your
definition was important to you. Like holding to that definition.
So I'm asking in the definition that you gave there as you used
it in that sentence, what's the definition? >> The definition
I've just given you. >> Well, no, no, cuz you don't think
that it's dogs information because she doesn't have a private
online persona. You said that you don't think that it's >> Well,
no. But what really break it from the definition is that I wasn't
the So I said this before, right? Interested the camera and [__]
Nobody,
maybe you disputed this at the time, but nobody else, but I was
basically explaining um that I like I'm not the one that established
the link here. She was already doxed, right? So, I spread that
doc.
>> But I thought a second ago you said that it it didn't
count as doc information because it's not private profile. It's
just as bad as >> So, I've just said to you, I don't think
that spreading of docs and doxing are like are like entirely
synonymous, but I think the distinction is >> I pointed
out the fact
I'm saying I'm asking what your definition is now. You said a
second boxing. I'm asking this what the I'm asking I'm asking
you what the anonymous
>> your question is like really it just like has no relevance
weird
>> I'm asking how that definition applies here to Leia's
wife she doesn't have a public I don't think I don't think that
I dox her I think I've spread her doxed though but I understand
why would consider that doxing right >> I'm saying definitely
under your definition and this is kind of the issue that we got
got into yesterday
she can't be doxed
>> okay under the definition
>> no I think that that would be like technically a part
of doxing Lio cuz I consider that you're linking her to like
the anonymous online persona of Lios that be like a part of doxing
Lios and she'd be affected by that right.
>> Sure. Um >> so like if I leaked let's say your
dad is like a really famous person or whatever and I leaked that
that was your dad. No sorry not it doesn't have to be a famous
person. Let's say your dad was just like a a businessman. Nobody
knew who the guy was. He's just like a businessman. And I linked
your dad's like name and website to you. I said this is Dicker's
dad. I would have just docked you like under my definition. Right.
But your dad would have also been a victim of that.
And I don't think that that distinction is necessarily like unfounded
or that crazy to say
regardless of the spreading of someone's docs even if the link
was already initially established is completely wrong and shouldn't
happen and that's why I was wrong. Right. So I don't think that
the I think getting like fixated on like uh this like on like
the des when I think the moral weight is exactly the same. I
don't think that's really like productive
>> Um but I mean you can proceed if you want. I just I
just think dialogue, right? Well, I guess that the question would
be I mean Jason look in chat. Who gets harassed with that dog's
information? Like I guess who would actually be the victim? Especially
given the fact that Lio is like a controversial person, right?
It would be his wife who's received harassment. >> Yeah,
she would also be a victim. Yeah, that's why I also like just
said like approximately like 30 seconds ago that in that case,
right, the dad and the analy would also like be a victim. So
I
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Absolutely.
>> Like like I just said, just for being clear, I just
said that. >> Okay. Okay. So, if this is if this is the
state that this content has put you in, do you see that as an
issue with continuing doing it? >> No, cuz I think that
it was like stupid to be online while I was drunk, so I should
just like put my I mean, I kind of wish you stopped me from being
on my phone, but I No, like I got
>> No, I'm not. I'm just saying
totally
>> metaphorically metaphorically. I don't know. I thought
it was >> You wanted me to take your phone away from you.
>> He has to take him out now. Stand there and watch. I
was arguing with you the entire time. Don't get hyped up by this
soul argument that he's been running with that I'm somehow because
I didn't tackle you and take your [__] >> wrong.
I'm saying like I >> You saying that it's weird to stand
there and watch. >> Yeah. Yeah. I >> insinuating
that's what I was doing.
>> I wasn't doing that.
>> To be clear in the chat, >> you were right. But
that's okay. You have no obligation to stop that, right? >> No,
no, no. I I I was trying to stop you. I was trying to persuade
you to stop. I was trying to tell you to get off the phone. I
was trying to tell you to get off the call. >> Okay. Like
I just just to be clear, I just said that Dickers has no obligation
to do this. So it's like a little weird to be clarifying as if
I expect him. I just said I wish, right? I didn't say that. I
>> You're insinuating that I am permissive of this. >> No.
Okay. That was I don't even So
I just clarified that that's not what I'm attempting to.
>> So it's like a little weird. You're still going by the
initial insinuation. I've just said I don't think that's your
>> I'm not talking about what the obligations are. I'm
talking about the descriptive that I'm somehow permissive of
this. But okay, if you're saying that I'm absolutely not permissive
this, I was trying to stop you the entire time. That's totally
fine >> cuz I know that Soul has made these >> There
was a
go that far. I wouldn't go that far, >> dude. I Aiden has
no idea how kind these people are being to >> There's no
insinuation, right? I I've just explicitly clarified there was
no
>> No, no, dude. Okay.
An obligation and failure to meet an obligation is a moral is
a moral description about whether somebody's worthy of condemnation.
What you were clearly insinuated that I should have or rather
that I was permissive of this. It was weird for me to stand there
and watch you do this. I did not just stand there and watch you
do this, did I? >> I mean, you did, but I don't think that's
wrong. >> No, I didn't. >> You You did. >> I
told you to get off the call. I told you to get off the phone.
Eventually, you did get off the phone. Was that due to my inter
intervention or not? >> Did I get off the phone because
of your
>> Yeah. Would you have otherwise just >> hung up
on my I could have. I don't I don't know what my mindset was
though. I could have I wouldn't be able to answer you on like
I don't think we want dishonesty here. I wouldn't be able to
answer you affirmatively one way or another. I would >> I
think you've I think you've got your a be in your bonnet
>> because of the way this has all gone. I think you've
got some analy
insinuating that I was permissive of This is like really bizarre.
I'm telling you, I don't think you did anything wrong here. >> It's
not really bizarre at all. >> No, it like it is. It It
is. I think >> And then you come back and just retract
to the fact of you don't think I had an obligation to stop. >> There
was no retraction
realized how bad it was and you don't have to do anything wrong.
You said that it was that I was standing question of a desire.
>> It's so weird that she didn't take my phone away. But
but but but but
also
you didn't have to take my vote away. Okay. Why did you say it?
Why did you just say that? What was the goal of that statement
when you said it or disagree? An expression I was standing there
are two completely standing there and watching you while you
did this. That's not true, is it? >> That's not a fair
characterization at all. And the insinuation is there that I
was permissive of this and I could have done something else to
stop it. >> I don't know if you were permiss. You could
have you could have done something else to stop it. Yes. Yes,
you could have. But >> what? Tackled you physically assault
you attack. Dude, I was saying no, you didn't have to tackle
it. No, that was wrestle your phone. >> I don't know if
that guy's a king, Auggie. But I do know that Stylo brutally
him verbally on some Twitter space today. Okay, it was so dude.
Silent rolled in. That was kind of gangster. He like rolled in.
He's like, you got to mute your audio right now cuz I'm going
to [__] I'm going to up and then muted. Silent just
hard this guy multiple times instantly. It was pretty funny.
Uh, no. Dumpy came on and then left and then Stylo came on and
just tore this guy apart. It was really >> out of your
hand. That's what you want me to do and then take it away for
the rest of the night
take away for the rest of the night. I would have been like,
"Oh my god, are you 12?" Like, holy. >> Yeah, that's why
he doesn't have an obl. It's weird. Like, if you think anyone's
saying that he has an I don't personally don't think >> Nobody's
claiming that you think that I've got an obligation to do this.
>> No, I don't think that I've accepted you think I've
got an obligation. >> You're saying So, you think that
I have an obligation to do that? I'm literally explicitly saying
>> I'm not saying obligation. I'm not saying that. I've
never said that. >> Okay. What I'm saying is there's an
insinuation
that I'm permissive of this you wish that I' like your phone
out of your hand you have an obligation to do that right as I've
said now >> I've never taken I've never t I've never taken
issue with the fact you what do or don't think I'm an obligation
the word obligation is not what I'm taking issue with that's
totally fine >> yes I don't
permissive this stuff will you say that I was not permissive
of this and that I was trying to get you to stop correct >> you
were you were I I believe you were yeah you were passively impermissive
of this yes >> I was permissive of this >> impermissive
you were not permissive of this you're Massively I was trying
to get you to stop. >> It's so crazy. >> I think
you made a few comments. >> We literally got in a screaming
match in your hotel room. >> You think I made a few comments?
I don't know why you're trying to do this. The only the only
reason the only thing this gets, by the way, it doesn't take
any blame off you. Nobody's listening to this and thinking better
of you. You're just trying to [__] to talk me. >> No,
you absolutely are. This is out of spite. You're trying to You're
trying to imply that I was like, I don't know. I could have done
more. >> Bizarre that you should be crashing out. I'm saying
I don't think you did anything wrong.
It's okay. Like, you don't need to be that defensive. I just
>> passively impermissive. Maybe I made >> my desire.
I didn't know that would offend. I'm sorry. >> Okay. I
mean, like, look, I'll be honest. I like I don't really want
to sit here and litigate like Lio [__] and I I I'll
just be clear. I feel like I've defended you, Aiden, to Lio to
other people. Um, I defended you during the Nick stuff. I defended
you multiple [__] times with [__] >> And
you've had to besides that you have to defend me over. I think
I've been relatively fine.
I think I think people have I think people have like even within
general stuff people who've given you I've had your corner a
little bit. This is not me just go waiting for the downfall of
Aiden. I think this was a crazy thing to do and like you may
say that the coverage is fine. I think if it's having this like
effect on you maybe you should take a step back from it. I don't
know what this with goat is or with anything else but if you're
getting like drunk and pissed off to the point where like you
know someone brought up a comment from three years ago and you're
like imagine getting this mad over internet beef like dude it's
it's [__] unhinged. I think with Lio in particular,
his actions like take this beyond the scope of just like the
person who should be covering it then, right? >> I think
my coverage has been relatively well grounded. I'm going take
that engage with intoxicated, right? That's why this was a one-off
incident, not a pattern. That's why you couldn't really site
other >> and I take the L on this, right? It wouldn't happen
again. It hasn't happened before. Great year. Um, and yeah, that's
like all you could really say, right? >> I mean, you've
become you've become
angry and unhinged over time, right? This isn't just like a one-off
thing. >> Oh, I'm angry. I'm I'm angry at him. Of course.
The question is, have I done
in this in >> Where on the doll did he touch you? >> I
mean, you've I mean, >> he didn't I but I didn't like that.
I didn't like that he was he was e touching someone else's he
was encouraging someone else's kid to like >> No, you're
saying you're saying this just not it's just not accurate. >> Wait,
that was a I said that I said that I said that in a jokey tone.
The the accurate descriptor The accurate descriptor would be
Huh? >> He advised someone else's kid to keep film CE.
He did. We
>> Dickers looks
>> Dude, Dickers has been gentle with this guy cuz they
are friends. He doesn't want this guy like totally. Okay, I'm
joking when I say he's like taking advantage of him for money
and all this. Although he's making a lot of money and I'm very
jealous. Okay, it's Dude, he's being gentle still. I like they're
entertaining this idea when he goes, "No, I see chat's private.
You have to prove that it's not private." It's like, "Shut the
up you. You have a 100 person chat. It is not private. Shut up.
Stop saying that. Like the fact that they entertained it at all.
That was incredibly kind of them. Okay. Incredibly kind.
>> He actually he is being kind. And then and then he goes,
"It's just weird that you like let me keep my phone." And then
says, "Actually, actually, that wasn't me saying you should take
my phone. I wasn't saying you had to take my phone. I was just
saying it's weird you didn't take my phone." Dude, it's such
rat behavior. It's such rat behavior that's happening. talking
to your ex on video. >> He has that is one comment which
like flies in the face of everything else said about that drama.
>> Wait, Becca, just to be clear, just to be clear on the
Stardust stream, did Leo not admit to to recommending a 17-year-old
to film CE some of >> He said like I I think the craze
was like we told them afterwards, but that's the first time I
>> Yeah. So So to be clear, so agree
again, I'd go with what Jordan said because Jordan never made
that claim. >> Why would we go? Why would we wait? Isn't
Hasn't Jordan made a document that was allegedly filled with
lies according to like liars? >> Why should you care? >> So
wait, so no, no, because I'm saying he's Becket is using Jordan
as a reference point for someone we should rely on, but your
own people your own people call Jordan a liar when it's beneficial
to you. So how can we be using So why should we be using Jordan?
>> Why should you to be defending Jordan >> I'm not
saying Wait, Jordan was 17. Jordan was a minor%.
I don't care how bad or good of a person Jordan was. I am saying
you shouldn't encourage a minor to film of themselves. I don't
care what they did that led up to that. >> I want criticized
to hell and back for that entire conversation even happening.
>> Yeah. So, how is what I said inaccurate? >> Because
what you're because again you're dealing with a situation where
they had gone through every single process. They'd gone they
tried to go to the police. They tried to remove Jordan from this
like house. They' like >> Did call CPS? >> I believe
I don't know who called >> uh did Lio look into emergency
youth shelters in Jordan State because they exist for [__]
sake. He did. He did. And Lio called these shelters. >> I
believe so. If I recall, >> you believe so. Is Lio willing
to sit on the record. He called these shelters. >> Drama
from like 2 years ago. The point is they'd gone and contacted
multiple people. Lio accepts that that's the wrong thing to do.
My issue here is my No, my issue here is not defending Loy over
this. My issue is you're taking that and going, "Well, Lio's
clearly a risk to children. You're talking off and this is this
is the thing. You say it like it's a really flippant thing."
That's a serious accusation, mate. And if this >> It is.
And I And there's basis for it. There's I'm using Lio's own words.
I think the logical conclusion of Lio's own words would lead
you to a con like and by the way sound like it's an isolation.
Look at how this guy treats vulnerable people in general. Right.
Lio actually Lio thought it was appropriate to have a minor on
stream with somebody he was alleging was grooming them to have
them in the same call.
>> Yeah. This guy this guy has placed himself in positions
where he's has responsibility over vulnerable people and in some
says those vulnerable people are minors and he has shown a complete
lack of intelligence that makes it reckless for him to engage
in the way that he does and when confronted with giving up his
position by people like Mali he's shown no interest in doing
so. So with all of those facts and aggregation yeah Lio is a
risk to people's kids. Absolutely. >> He he did give up
all that. But I have a question. What do you what do you remember
what Jordan's claim was that instigated the whole recording thing?
the whole record.
>> Jordan's claim was that the mother's it was like that
the mother's boyfriend was coming in at night or and touching
them,
>> Yes. Um, and is it unreasonable to say if you call the
cops and call CPS and all these organizations and with this claim
that they're not going to be able to do much because you can't
really prove that you're getting touched or groped actually was
her exact words, by the way. >> Yeah. So, just to be clear,
an investigation wouldn't be launched if the police are informed
by a minor that the just being inappropriate. >> Well,
I I'm aware of that. Yes. Like, but but >> that's Lio's
version of the story and that doesn't >> I mean, wait,
wait, wait, wait. A minor can report something like that to to
like their school counselor. >> It was the mandated It
was the mandated reporter, the school counselor that allegedly
went to police and then
>> Absolutely. There was not even nobody's even claimed
investigation was launched. >> What happened? I can't believe
this is like are we using this as another opportunity to mo about
liboy
you through your own stream. No, I need to address this. So just
>> No, I'm telling you even the conversation is and it's
worthless. >> Okay, so dickers the only reason you would
say that I'm sorry this is like disgusting levels of sweep to
be clear.
>> No, I'm bored of this. I don't care about my comboy.
>> Wait, wait. Beckett was referencing my prior coverage.
He >> I was referencing it because you tweeted you messaged
out in a leaked message about how it's justified because Lio
Convoy told a kid to make >> Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Yeah. Yeah. So, Becket Becket. So, Becket, so Becket, so Becket,
so Becket, so Becket Becket, do you think that me responding
to that is relevant to the conversation considering you brought
it up? >> I mean, sure, it can it can be relevant. My point
Dickers disagrees with you under Okay, sure. No, I'm disagreeing.
The problem underlying point is at this point you are clearly
highly emotionally invested in this story to a level where you
are I don't think you are seeing it clearly and I think it is
affecting your judgments to the point where you have got drunk
started tweeting out louy's wife and I believe saying that this
was your way to getting him into a call to to like have it out
with him and that level of emotional compromise that you are
currently under is my criticism of
>> Yeah, but do you not think there's like you you're admittedly
like
I'm looking stuff up in the background. >> Do you not think
it's like like
>> I'm I'm on Aiden's like Filmont right now grabbing logs
cuz I'm annoyed
all this stuff anyway. >> Do you not think it's weird to
refute my claim? That's literally just a reiteration of Lia's
own statements about what he did. No, because in this case I
don't think that statement that liar made I think it's an like
a like very contracted version of that story cuz my >> Did
he lie?
>> I I think he's like misspeaking but I don't think it
was just >> I don't believe that Jordan was ever told by
Lio to actually do this. She's >> Okay. So, so he so your
your defense for for him claiming that he advised a minor to
film child abuse material of themselves is that that was just
a
>> I mean it it's consistent with Jordan saying it never
happened. So >> no, just be clear. You think that Okay,
you can't re Gilded. Is Jordan a known liar or not?
>> Okay, you do realize Jordan went after Lio, right? >> Yeah.
Is but is Jordan a known liar? It would be in Jordan's best interest
to >> that wasn't my question.
Jordan is a known lie. >> Okay. But but >> yes, but
the point is >> so why are we using Jordan as a source
for credibility?
>> Do you think that convoy is very very >> See,
the only thing that we've got for certain and this is why I don't
believe like Lio told Jordan is because in the >> this
is such a waste of time. Okay. The reason this is a waste of
time is specifically because even if Aiden is correct about this,
it literally doesn't matter, right? It it it like matters 0%.
Even if this guy is a terrible person, he's saying all this cuz
he wants to keep covering this guy and wants to keep going after
him and nobody else is doing it. It's like, okay,
fine. Um I just move on. It's like so stupid to keep going to
this and you guys keep letting him like bogged down in this conversation,
which is not really relevant to anybody. I don't super care if
he keeps covering like Leo Comboy. Who cares, right? >> This
is discussed. It is Lio Vida and I believe Coyote. Jordan is
not in that call. The minor is not in the call. And during that
call itself, I believe they shut down the idea of being effectively
doing so
with there was another there was another conversation that has
happened from you need proof of everything. So you're now we
have a statement. No, we have a statement of Lio saying there
was a conversation the minor. >> Do you think that
is an honest person? I >> Hold on, Vlad real quick, cuz
I don't want to do like >> Did he lie about this? >> No,
no. I'm asking you, Aiden. Do you think that Li Convoy is a liar?
>> Oh, yeah. >> Do you think that he's an honest
person? >> I I think that he's not an honest
>> Okay. So, you don't think Jordan's an honest person?
You don't think Liar is an honest person? But you're choosing
to take Liar's word over Jordan's. Why? >> Okay. Well,
there's no information.
All right. Wait, I'm sorry. Just be clear as well. Is Jordan
claiming that Lia never had this discussion with them? >> I
just said that. Yes. >> Can you prove up? >> I don't
understand. They can spend 16 hours, entire years going over
all this and then >> Yeah, you you went over this a lot.
Can you provide evidence of this?
>> Uh, go find her video.
>> Okay. So, Lio did the same thing where he claims that
the evidence of harassment was in his Bunny Chan video. So, I
sat through the full 2-hour video and there was no evidence.
>> Why are we talking about Lio Convoy's Bunny Chan video?
>> That was just like a quick reference. I don't know why
you're haring on that. Most people ordinary people use I don't
you can just say I don't really any bizarre that did just one
more getting mad at like a >> Beckett's conversation about
the fact that you are mentally warped by Leo you've already agreed
with this no
for admitting to asking a minor to produce
>> you hated before that this is cope this is the like
again >> that's not what you going because he fell in love
with goat k I also hate >> no no we've had a conversation
in private Aiden where you said that that's Not true. That's
that's not what you care about. What you care about in that situation
that dickers has a million
examples. He can just like suddenly remember that
what you've said is that liio convoy the thing that really annoys
you about that situation is that they didn't tell me
a better solution like >> going to a different uh going
to a different home going and seeking out better resources.
That's what you really cared about. No, no, no. Dickers, dickers,
what I've said about this and you can verify this cuz any cuz
for for this to work, we have to believe your word and I've disputed
your word repeatedly. So, we would then have to bring public
ad so nobody has to trust either of our words. If you look at
my public retelling of this, I repeatedly state exactly what
you just said except the gripe is that that's not what really
annoys me that I think that the excuse that that was Lio's only
option is lie. Right. And I explain why. >> Yeah. Yeah.
Exactly. So you don't actually care
about the production of the you don't care about that at all.
>> You care that they didn't give them better advice.
>> But you're throwing out the cuz that's like an impactful
thing you were able to say. This person was like what 17 and
like 6 months old. This was never expected to be distributed
to anybody. This was something that they'd be sorry. Did I say
16? 17. Yeah. >> That they'd be able to like give give
over to the police. There's no there's no idea that this would
end up in the hands of somebody who would
dickers. Dickers dickers dickers. Not only that, not only hu
Dickers, not only did is that the case that was their entire
plan was to give all that to the police to have her give that
all to the police. Like he is completely disregarding reality
to form a narrative. That that is all that's happening here.
I'm using his own admission. Footage of a minor being abused
is
>> You've already accepted, Aiden, that the production
of that is not what you care about at all. It's the potential
lying as you said. And give it
you said what you realize.
You said what your real gripe is. >> Okay. If your clip
is the fact that they lied about the intention I want
to information
>> clip where I admitted that cuz that also didn't happen
and this just attests to why like >> what did you say your
real gripe was with this situation?
what did you said your real gripe was? >> No. So what I
was saying to you was I know what you're referencing. What you're
referencing that was my grievance with Lio's defense, not my
grievance with the situation itself. Okay. Do you care in and
of itself about the production of Do you care about that? >> This
you're lying again. >> In I'm asking you the question then.
In and of itself, do you care about the production of the
>> Or do you care that they didn't or do you care about
it in so far as they weren't given better advice on how to handle
the situation?
>> Wait, I care both. But the fact that a minor should
just get like and film it, I care about that as well. Yes. >> No,
no, no. and of itself versus
>> does dickers let these combos go on so long for advo
>> yeah at some point I think this is hard when it's the
same size creator as you augi like you're bigger and I think
you've been through a couple of these dickers is fairly new it
cuz I had the same problem I had like conversations go on forever
it's like so many of these questions like that doesn't matter
shut the up don't go down that path no you can't go down that
path or else just leave right but I think he knows that the content's
there and he can milk this for a while. So, I think it's some
it is something like that. That is a whole long-winded speech
just to say you're probably not anywhere
that Yeah, exactly. That's the whole point. And you don't care
about the production in and of itself. You care about them being
black and white about the quality.
You can No, I'm asking you to isolate them real quick. Okay.
You don't care about the about the production in and of itself.
You care. They weren't given better advice. They weren't told
to do something else.
>> Yeah. So, I care about the production and the excuse
that that was the only option is a lie because getting better.
What is like hard to accept about if you get caught up on that
statement, you're clearly arguing. How do you prove it's a
>> Because I've literally looked I've literally looked
in to the other options. Sorry, I don't I'm not going to dox
them. Um, but the the place that they were living in at the it's
not even a dock public, but the place they're living in at the
time, right, literally has like uh youth shelters that you can
stay in at that age. I think you're like above in for like 24
hours, right? So if they believe they were going to be abused
that night, um they could have gone to those shelters >> for
24 hours. Okay, that's that'll fix the problem. >> Then
that at least buys you 24 hours to figure out what the [__]
to do. Then you can say you've exhausted every option. Then you
can say that >> all right. What the >> do you not
Wait, are you disputing that that's an option? >> Uh they
already called the cops, called CPS, called all these people.
The claim is that was the only option. >> But but then
but then what they should have done is after exhausting those
options go to a shelter for 24 hours where they then contemplate
on what else to do after that when there really isn't much contact
the [__]
find out find out find out somewhere else they could crash after
go.
Anything is better than letting a kid get. Yes.
be clear. >> Wait, he just lost. He just gave up the argument.
Anything is better than getting a kid touched. Okay. So, including
recording, right? You just you're basically just worried about
the bar here. Was recording required yet? That's what you're
you're not actually worried about him recording it. So, you don't
think that that's the problem. It's over. That should be it.
That should be it. He just lost. He just gave it up, right? He
just said, "Well, anything's better than a kid getting touched."
If you had to record the parent touching the kid, if the kid
had to set up a a hidden phone or something to record their parent
abusing them to get out of the the house, then yeah, >> Right.
To be clear, if you can accept that that was an option, then
the claim that they exhaust every option is >> you're right.
Okay. Okay. Okay. You're right, Aiden. It was a temporary option
for 24 hours. >> So, just
>> wait, hold on real quick. Tam doesn't need to be distributed.
I never said that. Just to be clear, the definition of stands.
I said that it wasn't going to be distributed. Just let's get
back. >> That's not [__] fishing. They said
they exhausted every option. I found an option that they didn't
exhaust. They exhausted every possible permanent >> Obviously,
it's a lie to say that they exhausted every single >> They
exhausted every permanent solution.
I mean, I think again, we're getting off the point here. The
point is I think that you are emotionally compromised covering
this LIO convoy stuff. I think it's giving me brainworms. >> Yeah,
but I honestly I think the defenses here like really troubling.
I've got to be honest. Okay. Again,
I've criticized Lio for this. I don't I don't really I think
him being involved with it at all is ridiculously. Okay. I've
said that multiple times. I've cons consistently said this. It
doesn't matter. It almost doesn't matter whether Jordan was told
at all because the hunting is but he's like this is this is worse
than you're not directly
dude like the moral is just conxed.
Why do we care about why morals are >> it's not about allowed
to say it though it's selective application of morals. I hate
you guys.
It's the fact that okay well I think Brits are allowed to say
>> I'm annoyed at you for doxing lies wife. I think you've
lost your [__] mind. My response to you doing that
is not oh well time to time to release Aiden's docs now it's
fair game. That would be an overeotional response. I'm calling
you a re and saying you're compromised and saying that you're
like spiraling on streams going well >> I don't think there's
I think I've been just to be clear. Sorry I didn't mean to interrupt
you but I just want to say people keep saying this. I think my
responses tonight have been like totally coherent. I don't I
don't see like >> is have I said anything tonight that
you find like particularly like egregious or crazy? I think the
fact that you can't see that this coverage of this topic has
clearly had pretty weird impacts on you is concerning. Yes, >> I
know. I agree. There's unique like I do hate this person more
than anyone else I've covered. >> I've said I've said before
with other topics that when you when someone is super emotionally
invested, it affects their coverage. They make huge mistakes
sometimes. And right now, the only thing you've caused if you
believe Lio Convoy is a risk and like seriously needs to be dealt
with. You are detrimental. Detrimental to actually doing anything
about it cuz you are right now Lio Convoy's biggest defense.
Look how crazy these people are. They went and [__]
found information on my wife and screaming about it just cuz
I wouldn't talk to him. Do do you not think that that's just
helping Lio >> this this uh this occurrence? Yes. So I
think the solution would be to not do something like that.
>> So we're not we're not we're not going to do that. >> Yeah.
I think the solution generally would be to find some other like
take a >> Well, because I don't I don't Nobody's >> Becket
is actually just an aid gang for life member. Okay.
issues
get back on track. >> I guess you could say
>> I guess if I Okay, saying that I've covered something
for a large quantity time is not that's not really like a good
argument. >> It's not it's not about large quantity Yeah.
It's about like your emotional investment of it in >> Yeah.
So So I understand I understand. So what you're saying, correct
me if I'm wrong. What you're saying is that the problem with
my coverage is that it led me to do this. That's the issue. >> And
why I should probably subway because it makes me emotional.
>> You know what? I think that's a I'll give you that.
I think that's a fair argument from an outsers's perspective.
I think that I could avoid I'll even bet you on it. I will never
>> unaware of this wife. >> Let's let's talk about
this from another perspective. How do you feel about the fact
that you've got so emotionally invested in the story in this
community that now you've ended up in a similar position to the
one just dog was in? >> The one was in a similar position
to the one he was in. >> You got emotionally invested with
somebody who you were defending as part of the story and tried
to start a relationship with him or like at least pursuing some
kind of relationship with them. Right. >> Well, I don't
think I I said this. I don't think JTock did anything I I honestly
I don't think J did anything wrong pursuing someone that was
related to his coverage. I think the problem >> was that
I I felt that I felt that Cherry uh was not wasn't capable of
keeping a relation like keeping the details private. So my disagreement
and contention which I >> clearly clearly clearly this
has all gone public as well. So I don't I don't know how. >> Yeah,
but >> you know >> by my which it's gone public because
of my because somebody else made me a promise that they didn't
keep and then for the sake of humiliating me despite me doing
nothing wrong to them uh decided to attempt to yeah I guess just
like completely humiliate me on a stream and leak everything.
>> Do do you think your attachment to goat Kasu has also
emotionally compromised you in this story? Well, they're they're
getting my attach
because I've been covering my own story with um the Rosa call
which is
started with me. >> Yeah, you have. But you've definitely
stepped it up recently, right?
>> I've stepped it I think when he tried to insinuate I
was
um I think that's when I uh started stepping it up more. Uh,
and then like the total like flagrant behavior and the fact that
I was beginning to see calls that I had seen before that I've
never seen him apologize for. >> Uh, I talked about this
with Becket last night that he has.
>> Um, no. Becket Becket thinks this whole thing he has
this whole thing where if you're like if you do something that
isn't totally rational with regards to coverage, which again
I don't I didn't do. I literally said like it's it's backwards
here for them because what I said was if something was like unhinged
or wrong with my coverage, point it out. They're starting with
the thing Aiden did wrong to lovoy and saying I think it's because
of this relationship that you did it. I think you are emotionally
compromised because you did this wrong thing. Uh I can't nobody
can point to the wrong thing I did. >> In combination with
his like refusal to engage in a debate um or accept the criticism
that he believe >> sorry with regards to destiny the
Then I got increas
I mean he definitely doesn't he's never going to get on call
with you now right >> well he was just to be clear you
have you not admitted he was never going to get in a one >> well
so I thought there was a chance >> don't don't pretend
like this is the deal breaker he was never getting in a >> no
no I mean the difference is now I don't think there's really
an argument of he has to right he's he's pretty much >> he's
never had to get in a call nobody's argued that the argument
has been he's a >> well you've argued that he's >> The
argument is that he's acknowledged
Logic stream where I'm probably going to look like a [__]
cuz I am in the wrong. But I have no problem. I'm going to like
I have no problem going and doing that. And I think that I actually
have an obligation to go and do that because I have this expectation
of others. And Lio repeatedly has gotten on others for not showing
up. So I think that by him not showing up the in the months I've
been covering him is indicative of somebody willing to apply
standards to others that he doesn't apply to himself. >> So
he is obligated to.
>> Okay. There's no there's not a uh >> by his standards
he's obligated to. Nobody's going to put a gun to his head. Nobody's
going to >> Do you think Aiden's going to drive around
the town Lio Convoy's from just shouting his name hoping he finds
him
Auggie,
I've heard people I've heard some people have employed these
tactics.
>> That's crazy. By the way, take his phone and make him
enter into a call, right? It's about the moral obligation. >> Yeah,
I think there's a moral obligation for him to do it. Sure. He
doesn't have >> Okay. I don't know if all anybody ever
did was talk about me for days and days and months and months
and years and >> When I when I for one month, he wouldn't
talk either. Let's not Let's not lie. I've been challenging him
since I've begun talking about him and he wasn't willing to talk
back then and he's come up with a myriad of >> non-zero
chance he becomes a monster after this. Especially if after all
of this he still doesn't crack Gokado. Okay. If Gokado's she
has to understand she could stop a serial killer before he forms
right now. Okay. Can you take the hit and just for humanity?
All right. You could save multiple lives. >> Excuses, right?
>> Now you've given him a very real one to be fair. >> Okay.
But the past just to be clear then like the past would have just
been li those would have been lies. >> I mean his core
thing is he doesn't jump on streams and talk to drama streamers
about like his history and stuff. He's not really done that and
he's been consistent on that. >> Didn't he didn't he talk
to on stream? I think he's talking to being >> on stream.
Yeah. Where >> it wasn't even that critical. >> Yeah,
it wasn't. I get I agree with you. Totally agree. I'm saying
that's why he showed up for that one, right? Cuz he's lying about
why he doesn't show up. >> But he's turned up on again
like we've had this conversation privately, but he's turned up
to very critical conversations of him that he knew would be critical
that he
can give an exact Okay, I'm going to give an exact quote. You
can do with it what you will. Okay. His exact reason for why
he doesn't want to go on on Aiden's stream is, and I quote, "I
am not going to go onto the stream of of an obsessive freak like
Aiden." >> Yeah. He's called everyone that doesn't like
him an obsessive freak. >> A lot of people. >> How
many of like base docks, name docs, >> My anger is like
totally appropriate. And I think like yeah, like spreading his
name. I don't I don't think it's I don't think it's anywhere
near like appropriate. I mean again like you can be annoyed at
this guy. I think there was again there wasn't
Didn't this guy literally didn't this guy literally like call
someone's school cuz he was mad
>> Yeah, but hold on hold on hold on. >> But it didn't
happen to you personally. So why would you is like literally
a >> Is anyone pretending that that's fine? Is anyone has
anyone pretended that that's fine? >> No, they're not.
But why does he think that I'm a lunatic for this one? This is
arguably way more
because you're taking it you you are taking it as if he touched
you. Like that's how far you're taking I've never made that claim.
>> Has Lio Convoy ever docked somebody's >> I said
you made the claim. I said that's how you're acting. >> Hold
on. Has Lio Convoy ever doxed anybody's family member? This is
like super easy one. >> Has he ever docked someone's family
>> The answer is
>> Becket. He hasn't doxed anyone's family >> No,
he's never docked anyone's family member. In fact, he's never
actually I don't I think he's phoned one person's parent, but
like in all the cases where he's talked to people's parents that
I'm aware of or were public, it was somebody where their parents
were like in the room or something or he got them to put them
on a call. He's not he's like >> that seems to have got
he's done that multiple. He did it to some like obviously mentally
disabled >> and he's never doxed anybody's family member,
right? He's got no he's just he's just gotten the fans. So this
is this is lower than I'd this is lower
he's called people schools and falsely reported them as shooting
threats.
>> Sure. But like again nobody's arguing that that's just
fine. >> Yeah. I'd argue that these things even though
they're not one to one, right? Something doesn't need to be one
to one to one for the level of like morality and depravity to
be comp right. Uh things don't need to be like exact when we're
doing a comparison. But he's I do feel like I could help Aiden
understand if I use myself as an example because he's always
said he says it to Quean a lot. I feel like it would probably
apply to me as much that like, oh, you're obsessed with Destiny's.
It's like, dude, why do you say that to us? Why are you like,
why do you say that to us? He he could maybe there's ways he
could understand this, right? He just he likes Destiny, but like
from the outside looking in, he does seem kind of obsessed with
this Lio dude. I don't even think he has to not cover the Lio
dude, though. I I don't know how they're letting him argue on
this. It should be really about the things he's done wrong if
they're going to do this stream. >> He's never gone after
somebody's
>> family members if he's got an issue with them. But that's
>> he's gone after
>> he's never gone after people in his them. He's never
targeted somebody's
>> Never done something. >> You can actually skip
through a lot of this. It turns out they're they're looping on
the same topics over and over and over
>> that's not doxing their family. So he'd >> he's
never done something that could have an impact on somebody's
family.
So he So he verbally abused their [__] mentally disabled
Discord mod for 4 hours threatening to contact their
>> That's not doxing their family. >> No, it's not.
And I just harassing their >> Do you shower? >> That's
threatening to that's threatening to harass them through their
family. >> You guys understand a comparison doesn't need
to be doesn't need to be one. >> Yeah. You say this every
time you have a conversation with people and everyone always
says yes.
You're saying you're saying that stuff doesn't have to be like
or that you've done something that's less bad than a convoy.
All I'm pointing out is that liar's never even steeped this low,
>> No, he's gone lower. He's gone lower. He's actually
done things that have had a real effect on people's lives. >> Mommy,
he's worse.
>> Yeah, I think I think the problem >> he's actually
[__] with people. But here's the problem that Lio
did not helpful spawned huge drama around him because of like
the
he would sink to. Yeah, absolutely. Rightfully so. Don't disagree
with you. Um particularly stuff around like Jax or Rosa or whatever.
And like that's the standard of you shouldn't be doing this.
you should be rightly criticized and ripped apart for it. Now
like again what you've done is like hitting on those levels and
because because you you kind of like you you give these provisos
of what lies about person who causes emotional stuff. You sound
like Lio from 2023. You just sound >> I sound like there's
been Okay, you sound like as if he's changed. We have yet to
hear he's never adequately
>> Just a small spoiler for about 5 10 minutes from now
when we have a break.
Kathy won again. Kathy Kathy won again. Unfortunately, I hate
to say it, but Kathy won again. >> I'm not I'm not saying
I'm not saying he's changed. I'm saying you are using these same
arguments and like
the verifications or >> well it's going to depend
you know argue you know the same argument can be used for two
different situations and in one case it can be correct and another
it might be the question is do the details correspond has said
that he goes after people because they are freaks or degenerates
or zoo files and in the case of people like Finnegan for example
who admitted on a call recently that he a dog there were clearly
some people that Lio has gone after who did deserve it >> yeah
but Lio says that by your justification so you're now saying
I have done a lot of wrong things, but so for those cases where
he's gone after genuine freaks, like you'd be fine with >> Yeah,
those things would So, so, okay, so just to be clear, we've already
accepted what I did was wrong. Just because those were freaks,
it also makes what Lia did wrong, even though I also think that
he's a freak. The argument comes down to I think
he's a bigger freak than me because Lia's behavior is a is a
pattern, right? I'm I've been around, once again, I'm doing content
for what, eight years. This is didn't care about what you've
done to Loyo. You've accepted earlier that the wife is also victimized
by this. >> Hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on,
hold on, hold on, hold on.
He's taking um Becket brought up the the stuff with me. And now
Aiden's going to Aiden thought about it and he's like, "Wait,
what was the argument JTO made when that happened?" Oh, right.
They were criticizing a pan. Oh, yes. He just he just went and
he heard the criticism like Becket brought up me and A was like
wait what did he say? Oh I I'll take that. I'll take that. >> He
claims that like someone's like >> so it doesn't matter.
Yeah but I'm saying it doesn't matter what
you complain so much. Okay. Let me >> You don't think a
pattern is relevant for a >> Okay. What I'm talking Let
me finish. Dude, you cry every time somebody cuts you off. I'm
letting you talk. >> What I'm saying Okay. What I'm saying
is that you've already agreed that it's victimizing not only
Lio, Lio's wife as
>> So you can't use things that Lio has done to be able
to justify things that you're doing to his wife. >> Cool.
And it doesn't lessen it. >> We've already admitted it's
Why are we really It doesn't lessen it. That's the >> Well,
I'm asking you did is very No, I'm asking you. It doesn't And
it doesn't And it doesn't lessen it,
>> No, it doesn't lessen Yeah. The act is still wrong.
I'm just saying in comparison, right, Li's way more of a freak
than I. >> It's not even close. >> Okay. And that's
relevant. How?
>> Because that's what >> because it sounds like
you're still trying to justify it, bro. >> Becket. No,
that's not a Dickers. >> He wants the moral high ground,
too. >> Dickers, it seems like you It's like frustrating.
It seems like you tune out. No, Becket's making no
argument that you do not have the moral high ground, that you're
using the same justifications as
>> No. Wait, but tickers, why is he >> you are in
the same realm as he argument in response to >> I'm making
it in the response to the fact that like clearly you know and
again this is an also important proviso to this like when liar
is doing this he's doing it in a community that actively encourages
it right the ACC is full of freaks full of doxers has been for
ages
>> why are they letting Aiden Spur for so long uh money
a big dick is making a lot of money 220 up to $220 for the donut
goal he's making a lot of Hey, sure, whatever. But like, you
know, like you know it isn't wrong. You know that this is like
an over escalation. And my criticism of you again is that this
content is driving you crazy and it's like driving you insane.
>> Once again, like I I feel like you'd have to be delusional
to anything I've said here crazy. I don't know what to tell you.
Like it's all you all you had to do was point and laugh and instead
you got emotionally invested. >> I don't want to just do
that. Like I think that this guy's like a legitimately bad person.
And it's more than him just being >> you would be you would
have you would have been a great great fit in Fox
>> Um weren't you in that server? >> I was in that
server but I wasn't a part of their >> I was never in that
server. >> I know
that probably would be right. You got plenty of lawyers haters
who like again this is what happened with Patchwork right at
the start of like you really doing this in earnest. you brought
on patchwork car and like patchwork car comes in makes a load
of claims about what's currently going on what cats is like and
then I just come in and go no that's not true like there are
plenty of people who are sniffing around who are giving you information
who have their own histories that you are not aware of >> yeah
that's why I don't platform their wait becket you understand
you can platform somebody without the understanding that you
agree with what they're saying >> yeah sure >> yeah
so so I I platform people I platform people who say things I
don't agree all the time >> yeah sure but at the same time
like you look at in isolation in this community. Okay. So, so
here's my question with this. Do you accept that the whole of
the ACC generally speaking like everyone has their skeletons?
Life is not unique or is he to you a unique evil? >> In
the people that are still around, he's the worst I've seen in
terms of because it's not just any one behavior in
that it's a pattern. It's a it's a pattern that has had a my
opinion a complete lack of correction. Uh and I you know once
again like all the people we can bring up you can find isolated
instances people make mistakes that the amount of mistakes uh
in comparison to his age as well is just like completely like
inexcusable. Uh and I the fact that he in my opinion has never
meaningfully taken accountability.
Hold on. What's what's this though? Cuz it's like you you've
said this before. It's like I don't think he apologized properly
for the Rosa stuff. It's like well right now it doesn't sound
like you're apologizing properly for Leo's wife. >> Yeah.
No I apologize. So So once again so I could say this again. It's
weird because I've already said this times and gone in detail
about why I think it's wrong. Uh so it's not just me saying the
right words. >> Um Aiden is trying to become a loco very
hard. I wouldn't say he's actually a loco yet. >> Once
again, right
for me to spread the docks of wise life. That's a little mistake
and obviously wouldn't happen again. Uh which is why it's the
only time this happened in 8 years. Um, I think that Lio continues
to exhibit a pattern of behavior that is involved directly getting
involved with and in Funkill's real lives uh um going after and
you know abusing vulnerable people uh advising minors in a context
that's not appropriate for him to do so. Uh and uh you know we've
already litigated that a thousand times >> in the last
two years. >> So in the last two years we're now having
further recklessness with the beans stuff. So although there's
not a
the pattern persists of the reckless behavior. Lio pulled up
the medical documentation of a vulnerable nobody.
The documentation shows this person attempted to take their own
Kathy win
Oh, we're buffering cuz we were catching
says that that doesn't prove anything cuz they could just go
in there and tell
>> Is this just another opportunity to like wax lyrical
that limit? I'm sorry. >> This has happened several times
now. I know, but you take anything that Becket says about Lio
as an opportunity to go on a whole spiel about another story
about why you hate Leo. >> Can I just be honest? Can I
just be honest with you? >> You absolutely can. >> Let's
say I Okay, can I just ask you >> Somebody asked me, "Hey,
when is this behavior continue? I didn't give an example of this
like reckless behavior.
How is there a criticism that I
I'm saying to you and Gilda Poo, I'm saying to you, I don't know
if a big comparison
about the
>> Well, yeah, because you were speaking at the time. >> Yeah,
I was responding to a question that Becket asked me and now and
now I've apologized. Okay, I apologize. I'm taking accountability
for it and I'm saying Aiden Becket Gilded Po. I don't know if
a big comparison between Aiden and Lia Convoy is going to be
like productive here. It's just gonna go into like spirals where
we argue about the particulars of live combo drama. >> Okay.
So, to be clear, it's not like and again, it's not I'm not saying
like Aiden's turning into Lio. I'm I'm literally just saying
that this has emotionally compromised him to such a level where
I think the content is clearly bad for him. And that's and like
regardless of what Lio has done, regardless of any of the and
once again and I'll say it for the millionth time now, I think
it is fine to criticize Lio Convoy. I think there is a lot there
to criticize reasonably. I I worry about what this is doing to
you. I think it is bad for you and I think that if you think
that after this happen like yeah I think I just need to you know
not do this again but I can carry on the coverage like nothing's
ever happened like it has no impact. I think you're [__]
delusional because obviously now when you do future coverage
uh like let's say you do find something about Liar well you'd
now be the worst person to find it
because it's like well isn't this a guy who like released information
on Liar's wife who will like dig through anything to find stuff
on him. I think that you have I think you're emotionally compromised
and now you're like publicly and optically >> Yeah. So
I so so we were talking about this the other night at dinner
and I think that the game plan is I'm actually probably not really
going to be talking about on stream plan is instead I'm going
to be investing time and effort into a video that's going to
not rely on my wording for anything. I'm going to be citing sort
I'm going to be citing uh video evidence of of Lio's own words
statement and the statements of others and um that he's like
a horrible person that should quit the internet and just like
a single video 40-minute video >> Do you think that's going
to make any difference? I I mean again like go >> It's
going to be easy because I feel like a lot of this it's not like
for example how many normies have heard or seen the Robert call?
Who the who the [__] Who? Okay, actually
about this like segueing into ways wax lyrical about stories
about Leo Comboy. >> I I
>> at least has like gotten to the point >> Here's
my question for you. What impact is this going to have? Because
no one in the ACC
fan of Lio cares. What normally is going to care? Who cares?
>> So it's going to So it's going to So it's going to So
it's going to have
creative outlet for me. um it's gonna kind of provide an organized
space uh to aggregate the points that I've kind of given in a
disorganized manner and >> concise place link people to
to understand like the the premise of my argument and I think
that's fine to do. We're we're we're YouTubers, right? >> Do
you do Yeah, sure. And I I completely that sounds great. My question
is again like what impact you think this had because I think
you could make an ironclad video saying that Lio had like done
all the that many of us know that he has done and it it it mean
it like it kind of just doesn't do anything. I don't I don't
>> I don't want you guys to know about I want I also a
big appeal like I don't think I'm going to put Lia's name in
the title. I want this to get out more into like the video essay
type audience like watch like and stuff. Um because I just want
like nonACC people to start learning about this guy. >> Okay.
Okay. Sure. Sure. >> Because I think like all the stuff
that I've listed on this stream to the average normie if they
were to hear it would be obviously I think this guy's the fat
freak that he is.
>> Yeah. So any questions, comments? >> No. Do what
you want. I don't I don't >> Anything else?
>> I don't Anything else? >> You don't know what
to Well, no. First thing you disagree with now is place to >> Anything
else? >> No. I mean, I I I disagree with you. I think it's
I think it's I think if you want to go down this like
slime beast type rabbit hole where you're just like or creepy
reading type rabbit hole where this becomes your
>> The video would be kind of the should be unless he does
something else. The video is kind of meant to be like the wrap
up of all my coverage, right? I've talked about this. I mean,
soul will v I was talking about this. If Perry's honest, Perry
will vouch. Um, I've been talking about this for
>> I mean, those videos already exist, >> I messaged.
>> Yeah, but I think they all suck.
>> She answered one question and then I basically was like,
>> I agree with some clarifying questions. >> Sorry.
I said, I I want to ask some clarifying questions about the Aiden
drama. If you want to talk about that, here's like my Discord
because I don't check Twitter DMs all that often. and I did not
get added on Discord. So, I'm guessing she does not want to m
Aiden in the back as much as I had hoped or thought yesterday.
Not even hoped. As as funny as that would be, I was just like,
I want to ask clarifying questions. She didn't want that. He
did answer a bunch of other questions. >> Aiden said this
in private conversation that he's making a video. >> I
think people I think Sorry. I think the people that have >> Sorry,
I say hoped. No, you missed yesterday, Auggie. like
>> previous digs at this guy are all like psychotic, boring,
unimain's
video on it is quite good. >> Was incredibly boring.
>> I almost like I fell asleep. Lanza did good research.
I just think Lanza doesn't like inject his personality enough
or or jokes or anything into his videos which makes his videos
like just personally boring to sit. >> Wow. I actually
agree with Aiden. Holy.
So, I want to make a video where I can >> have creative
input as well. >> Sure. And again, I think if that's your
intention, do the video and move on with your life. Fine. But
I I mean,
I'll just be straight up. I've always been like since you like
came back. U we've talked many many times. I've
I think always been pretty fair with you. Um
I take no joy in watching you like what I see as destroy yourself
like this. my >> Yeah, I I just I don't think I destroy
I think like my uh points stand for themselves. I don't think
any of the had against
reasoned and if people think that I'm a dick uh as a result of
this
>> this guy's given like 300. >> I guess you could
you could join the club. Uh I can be a dick sometimes. So yeah,
and I I'm owning it, right? I do own that. Uh but it obviously
wouldn't be something that would have happened twice. And that's
the difference uh between me and Lio, right? One's a pattern,
one is a more offense stones. Um, and yeah, uh, if you don't,
you don't have to like my personality, but, uh, my points stand
for themselves.
redheaded YouTuber. Thank you for the
Holy,
thank you very much. >> Okay, I'd watch nothing but 07.
>> There you go. There you go, Auggie. That's why Dickers
is continuing this. Okay. The of Aiden Underground is incredibly
profitable. >> Nothing but 07s. Thank you very much. >> All
right. Well, uh glad uh glad I don't want to run. So, if he has
anything, I'm probably going to head out. >> Are you still
going to have to call with >> Oh, yeah. I'm going to I'll
have a combo with Chad. Sure. >> Okay. Um All right. Is
there anybody else? Dude, the 404 wants to like get in the conversation.
Is this going to be productive? I don't know if it is. Um
>> Yeah. I'm going to give him two minutes.
Is it Kathy? >> No, Kathy can Kathy wants to call in as
well. Um, how's it going? 404, welcome to the stream. Welcome
to the stream. You've got 5 minutes. >> Excellent. That's
all I need. Um, so
>> what's up, man? >> Yeah, not a lot, man. Look,
I you know, I'm not trying to jump on the bandwagon or the hate
train or whatever. Um, basically, man, all you need to do here
is you can't compare what what what liar does to what what has
happened with you. Um, I understand that may have been an underlying
underlying um, you know, sort of thing like, well, he's he's
a piece of, but um, you know what? His wife's not involved. She
hasn't involved herself. You involving her has made you look
like a piece of [__] and it's compromised coverage.
>> Um, that's pretty much it, man. Um, >> I completely
agree with you, sir.
>> Wow. In basically 30 seconds. All right, Kosha Kathy,
you're up. Welcome to the stream, Kathy. Welcome to the stream.
>> hello. I think uh you all been so hard on Aiden. I have
been supporting Aiden since the start. Boo, shame on you. Dickard,
shame on you. Aiden hasn't done anything wrong. I think when
Dickard saw you on Q farm, he said, "Oh, I saw Aiden Farm." It's
because I told Aiden, Aiden, can you check Destiny Q farm thread?
He was on Destiny's Q farm. >> Yeah, that's totally something
I would >> That's what I
he was on. So, Aiden, I'm going to ask you this very I'm 100%
with you, Aiden. Everything you said is correct. Can you please
unban me from
>> You know what? Sure. >> Thank you very much. Thank
you. >> Yeah. Um >> I will never forget that. >> Can
I get unbanned from IC as well? >> You
I have to The thing is I don't like to make decisions. >> Agreed.
I confer with the council. Wait, I'm I'm going through a tunnel.
Agreed.
>> Okay, good one.
>> All right. So, good job, Dickers. Thank you for donators.
Thank you, Red House. Did you see uh Chad, you got owned. I fooled
you. You are a loser.
You you going to you going to >> Oh, yeah. You got like
you you called Chud and he thought that you were >> Yes.
Well, >> do you have a recording of that call? >> No,
no, no. But >> Cathy, dude, you missed a major [__]
trip. What are you doing? >> Certain people. Anyway, let
get inside. He gave you $100. I'm going to leave.
>> Nice. Nice. >> Um, just real quick. I do. I've
got [__] activity. Okay, the $100 was super super
insane. >> Okay, we're catching up. I think Beck is gonna
help us done. So >> hugely appreciate that. Uh yeah, I
did to the end of the stream though because we still got Becket
and Vlad. Thoughts, >> I'm glad to go first. >> Honestly,
I'm just waiting for >> I'm dying. >> I'll chill.
>> It's all I got. >> I'm a dehydrated gilded poo.
>> What are we doing? We're doing Nick Shirley into
I just I I think he's um out of his mind. That's I I don't
>> I don't get it. just chill. Um,
and I I mean, yeah, it's it's pretty much it, isn't it? What
do you meant to say? And I think if he wants to do a video, more
power to him, I'm sure that like if it's a good release for him,
>> but you should never be this invested in the content
you're covering. >> Look, Aiden convinced me. Okay, I I
I think you should actually continue streaming and make that
video. Maybe make it a trilogy,
>> actually. So, I'm convinced now.
We need to press this harder.
>> Press on. >> Go up now with the Akumu videos.
>> Make it nine hours. >> dude. He need Yeah, I need
to do a
>> I think it's sad to see another person just to like
get like absorbed into the ACC in this particular way and just
uh I don't know. >> I see I up I said a perfect fit for
uh Fox Mafia. I meant to say ACC.
So, whoops. But yeah, like he he sounds exactly like an ACC [__]
It's weird, but you know, whatever.
>> Too much time with goat cat. That's my my diagnosis.
>> Yeah, goth chicks. Never never once. Never once. I mean,
that's it. I I just >> London never too much. But but like
Yeah. I just think it's uh
>> I think it's a shame. >> I'm just happy to see
that we have Beckett and Knockoff Beckett in the same call. Dickers
and I talk all the time. We've done done this. >> I'm out
of Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Go cattle came in
at the end. Hold on. Hold on. >> It's confusing to I I
keep on forgetting whether Becca has said something or I've said
something, but you know, we managed to quibble through it. It's
okay. We get there in the end. >> He's been a good clone.
He's my most successful one.
>> I'm glad. I'm glad. >> God, what awful stock to
come from. Jesus Christ. Can we get some clarify clarity from
goat Kato as to whether like what exactly happened? >> Um
and also why she keeps >> I am being that shameless. Yep.
I'm being literally
>> Yep. That is the level. Let's double >> Can somebody
Okay. Is she in chat right now? If you type in >> straight
up, >> straight up. >> Go Kato,
come on down. You are absolutely welcome to join the stream if
you would like to. >> I will hop in for that if they'll
have me on. I just I just want to know what happened. I want
to know how like the Egoth girl destroyed this boy. >> Okay.
It's brutal. >> Where on the cooch did he not touch you?
>> Goat says I'm drunk. That would not be wise, I fear.
>> Yeah, that probably true as well.
>> Holy, I wish I drank during this call. Jesus Christ.
Um yeah, I think that's going to be about it. I don't know if
there's any more thoughts than anybody's got about any of that,
but there we are. >> Wait, wait. being on stream drunk
is the perfect time to come in here. What do you mean? >> Oh
my god. Okay. Look, I'm in a dip. Um, this has been fun as always.
>> Catch you next time. Peace. Too bad. >> Catch
you next time. Have a good one. >> Too bad. >> all
right. Well, we tried it. We tried it. We'll see what happens.
What's up, Becket? How's it going? >> Hey, buddy. How you
doing? How goes How goes the uh We doing the watch party.
Uh, I was pausing a decent amount and commenting. Um, mostly
sething at you guys for not keeping the com the conversation
on track. I think I could have joined, but like I don't
sick. >> Well, here's the thing. I think that's the problem
with having Aiden on is like I don't want to tell him that he's
being totally unreasonable and just like hard set reality for
him cuz I think that looks bad for him. But somebody has to do
it cuz the content was like it was okay. But it it like gets
bad when nobody's willing to direct it, right? >> Yeah.
I think part of the problem is as well thoughts on literally
every tiny
>> Yeah. Well, what about votes on everything? Yeah. Exactly.
>> And it really is just a waterm and I think that's a
that's a pretty major
issue. I And consistency does matter. I know people want to harp
on consist
hypocrisy hunting, but consistency is important as a creator,
I think. So,
>> yeah. Yeah. I think I mean, what's what's your overall
thoughts?
>> Um, well, we could go to overall thoughts. I was just
going to say because we could have this conversation first when
you bring me up. I think the difference with me and I argued
this at the time. I agreed it with you and you didn't have a
response. So, maybe you have a response to it now or maybe you'll
just say it's a solid difference. Um, with Aiden, you have an
example of bad behavior and then you're using that to say I think
there could be, you know, and you you have bad behavior and you
have possible negative motive, right? So, I think the negative
motive, the bad motive is causing the bad behavior. With me,
there's no example of the bad
>> People are like, "Oh, there's a possible bad motive."
But any of the bad behavior suggests are just outright lies that
I've literally said prove or substantiate in any way. Right?
You could say in and of itself it's bad behavior to get into
a relationship with somebody who you've done coverage on and
like that would be fine, but with Aiden it's like literally his
coverage has been warped noticeably, right? And I'm saying with
mine the coverage has like I can't get anybody to point to where
the coverage is warped notably. >> Yeah, I agree with you.
I think the the bad behavior on your part is the relationship
in the first place. But yeah. Yeah, I just I just agree with
you. Um,
I don't I think the argument I made at the time was it can be
it can be used to discredit you and therefore and the general
coverage, which is an incredibly stupid thing to do, which also
applies in this case with Aiden.
>> but that's that's like the main sort of thrust, I think,
of the lot of the criticism that you were going to get over that
and did get. So, yeah. >> Yeah. I I think that's stupid,
but I just don't think there's any reason to argue it. Like,
I I I disagree, but like it's I would disagree. So, I'm I'm just
willing to say I don't care to argue it. >> Otherwise,
that conversation.
>> Oh,
what's up, dickers? Kick viewers. He ended stream. >> Dude,
I I messaged uh Gokado on Twitter. She actually responded for
a little bit of it, and I'm like, "Hey, here's my Discord handle
if you want to I I want to ask you more questions about if you
want to continue this conversation." And she hasn't responded
to that. I just messaged I just said in that chat, I'm like,
"Hey, you should add me on Discord. You should come talk about
>> dude. I'd love to talk to Aiden. Okay.
>> Yeah. I don't give a [__] to talk to Aiden.
Okay.
But if we could talk to Gokado, that would be very cool. That
would be very >> I just I I mean again um like my biases
are kind of known in all this. I think one of the frustrating
things for me is
I've done all the like criticisms of Lio. I think like Aiden's
essentially going over stuff that happened years ago.
The environment Lio's in has completely changed. A lot of the
people who were also around with Lio are gone. Senate is gone.
Um,
and there's just an element of like, okay, well, I don't know
the the moral
frogging constantly
about this stuff is just I I mean, it's clearly breaking him
because Aiden a year ago would never do something like that.
>> Dude, it's Yeah, it's not even It's not even moral frogging.
It's like I don't think it's moral frogging. He's saying it cuz
it is like some reason to explain his behavior cuz he doesn't
just want to say that it's like literally I I think he just doesn't
want to say it's the relationship or the possibility of a relationship.
I think that's what it is cuz none of it makes it doesn't even
make sense. It's not even a good example. Like oh well I I get
really mad when it's about other people's kids. It's like bro,
I've watched you like totally dispassionately tell someone having
a mental breakdown on your stream that she is only doing this
because she's mentally ill and like she's crying and you're like
you're you're just mentally ill is all that's happening here.
like totally no no emotion whatsoever. Like I don't believe you.
I literally don't believe you at all.
>> Yeah, I'd agree with that. >> This is like objectively
a lie. >> I Yeah, I mean like I say this multiple times.
We're drama coverers. Like I cover like up things and laugh at
people suffering all the time. I think we all do. I think the
idea like well commentaries actually should be really ethical
and we're very ethical as commentators. I think it's just weird
cope. I think it's cope. I I don't really buy it. Um, I think
there are commentators who genuinely emotionally care and I think
their coverage is worse.
Legitimately, I think it I think it you >> that could be
true. Yeah, that could be >> Actually, I'll give I'll just
give I'll just straight up give the example. It me when I did
it. Um, like when when I gave a [__] about the Destiny
stuff last year, I was obviously majorly emotionally invested
in that story. I knew a lot of the people involved and it led
to me making terrible [__]
I shouldn't have. >> What do you think your were your terrible
decisions from that drama?
>> Um I think one but
>> Oh, I should have talked to Pixie as like the primary
one. >> Um I should have talked to Pix
>> Um I should have like a few more people and like Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. >> These are like the major
Yeah.
>> Only thing I would have basically said you give a heads
up and then that I think that fixes like a ton of the problems
that would have been there
>> Yeah. Yeah, I think I think it would have made a a big
difference, but I didn't do that, which should have been obvious
because I was massively emotionally compromised.
Um,
that's that's, you know, it's it's ridiculous to say otherwise.
And I said this at the time, right? And this is also one of the
reasons much like I'm saying to Aiden, I don't think he should
continue covering Lio Convoy or at least he should take a decent
break from it. when the Destiny stuff like happened, I stopped
covering Destiny um afterwards, I was just like, "Yeah, I'm gonna
I'm not gonna be involved in the rest of the drama. I should
take a step back cuz clearly I can't I'm not a good person to
do it, right?" >> Yeah, I think that could be true. I think
it it can be true. Um I understand I sort of understand where
Aiden's coming from that it feels like um this guy's really bad.
Like with me it's more um with me I'd say the reason I cover
a lot of the Destiny stuff or had been covering it like after
a certain point was the explicit harassment from his community,
right? Like from him. Sorry, I should actually say him even more
than his community. Like him straight up trying to dox people
in my Discord. Like explicitly stating he's going to dox people
in my Discord and then following
>> Oh, you're talking about Destiny stuff. >> Yeah.
Okay. >> Yeah. Well, I was just saying I understand where
Aiden's coming from when no one else covers it that it can feel
like, well, this guy's really bad. I have to cover it. But I
don't know if it was just happening to other people. I don't
know if I would,
>> you know what I mean? I feel like I could walk away
from it. It sounds kind of like that. >> Part of the like
part of the issue as well is there is an element where Aiden's
coverage has made it legitimately harder within the community
to actually criticize liar. Um,
there are things that have happened that probably would have
been talked about differently and like spiraled differently if
Aiden
wasn't also covering cuz like the stuff that happened with like
Hidden Heroin for example, the actual goat tattoo stuff. >> Oh,
wait.
Hold on. Hold on. >> Did Aiden know goat before that >> I
don't know. >> Were they close?
>> They weren't close. I don't believe
>> yeah it's like it kind of like hamstrings because like
when that goat stuff happened I was critical of Lio and I was
very critical of Hidden and I was like this is and I I said this
earlier on stream I have had >> okay hold on just just
lay it out really quickly Hidden is the moderator who is sort
of like making things up >> but like it's one of those
where I was openly critical of Lio and Hidden during that and
still got [__] for it cuz it's like
the narrative's kind of been painted in the hater community.
So now it feels like it's pointless to like say anything about
it. I I don't think Aiden's helped. And now Aiden's just given
the ultimate kind of defense for like a convoy. Look how crazy
these people are who were going after me. They tried to dox my
wife like you know.
At least gives them some kind of reason to what do you call it?
Some kind of reason to walk away from it. I will say um oh I
also thought dude I was also kind of losing it a little bit.
I felt like at least people weren't catching some of the arguments
he was making. I guess it's like kind of fatiguing sometimes
to be in the conversation for a while. But at some point he basically
just admits that like
well recording the video wouldn't actually be that bad if you'd
exhausted all options. And doesn't the conversation just end
there? Cuz he's trying to make it seem like in a vacuum the recording
is bad. He's that's the only context he's including, right? >> So
he's not even explaining it correctly. It it kind of just gives
away that he's being disingenuous the whole
>> Yeah. And again, this stuff's been litigated. Nobody
has sat there being like, "Oh, well, Liario was never criticized
for this Jordan stuff." He was massively criticized. It's the
scale of criticism. It's like you can criticize Lar Convoy for
being a hunter who like was
actively like not intentionally but his actions led to harm without
being like I think he was creating and he's a risk to children.
It's like you've taken that to such an extreme level it becomes
I've got to like pick apart the more extreme thing you've said
rather than just engaging with the like base criticism of itself
which may be fair enough. There's loads of things that liars
done that are very very easy and correct to criticize. And that's
I think that's been my core problem with a lot of the coverage
around them. It's like you don't need to go to these extreme
lengths.
You can just be like you can just be accurate and it would have
the same impact. >> Yeah. Well, I don't think it would
have the same impact. I think that's why he's not being accurate.
I actually I don't think you would it would have the same impact
at all. I I actually don't. I think I think that's exactly why
he's lying about it.
>> Okay. Okay. Right.
I don't know. >> Maybe that I that's a that's like an accusation.
He's consciously going I need to make this look worse. Which
I know people do do all that, Leo. Plenty of people do. I think
he's just like
>> I think he's like got no grace or charity for any of
the stuff around it
>> Yeah. Okay. Okay.
Sorry. I thought I might have misunderstood you. I might have
misunderstood you there. I thought you were referring to like
like that's why Aiden's lying in my opinion. He's lying about
it because it wouldn't hit as hard as if he was honest about
it. >> Oh, okay. No, no, no. I was on the same page as
you, >> but like Okay. Okay.
>> Yeah, I think Yeah, maybe.
>> I don't know. Yeah, this this all seems very [__]
and it's like it's it shouldn't be that hard. Aiden's been in
the game a long time. He knows the kind of rules.
>> Why do the most retarding possible? Were Were you in
the conversation
when he brought up Dicker's not taking his phone
>> I at that point I'm like, "Okay, the tom foolery stuff
is like way too >> like like now you're now now I'm actually
it's actually so crazy at this point. You're like blaming your
friends for letting this happen. You're blaming your friends
for like their reactions to your bad behavior and saying it's
like what is causing every all of the problems. It was wild."
And then and then he goes, "But I'm not saying you should have
done anything." It's like, "Okay, why did you say it then?" Literally,
what is the goal of the state? You say some words. You had a
goal with those words. >> The problem is he was like, "I
wish that you did this." And Dickers is like, "We I I tried very
hard to stop you. >> I was trying hard to stop you." What
do you mean? >> That was that was crazy to me.
>> Absolutely unbelievable, bro.
I do think this is making me think a little bit that possibly
>> Aiden might be fine
>> because there's like a certain kind of it reminds me
a little bit of Nick Lee too if you do you know who Nick Lee
is Amaranth's husband.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
Okay. I like he engaged in some really horrific behavior. Um
like not sorry not horrific not Leo convoy not even really Aiden
level just yeah probably Aiden level just in his relationship
he was like very very like cold with his wife just the way he's
handling stuff with his wife was pretty crazy but I said early
on watching I'm like dude he just he can yap infinitely and he
can like fight on everything until you're too exhausted to like
fight anymore. And I think sometimes that person might just win.
Like literally they're just going to argue with you forever and
they're never going to become exhausted by arguing. They only
get more powerful as you argue with them and like sometimes you
just eventually get exhausted. I haven't seen Aiden at that power
level yet though. Nick Nick literally would get in the 12-h hour
VC. Like I think he got in like a I think he like argued with
Amarrath for like 12 hours in a row then hopped on my stream.
It was in like 6 hours of VC arguing in this stream as well.
It's like okay that's that's some incredible [__]
I don't know if Aiden's there yet. Yeah, I think. Okay, so here's
my general take away from around this. It's like Aiden apologizes.
Uh he can say he didn't repeat the behavior.
My opinion is that it's like
you like I don't think I don't think you're done on the internet
unless you like delete your channel and quit yourself. Like the
only person who can really remove you is yourself. Like [__]
Tom Foolery is still around making content. But
um
kind of anyway,
I think the cool thing is this. It's like, okay, well, this is
this is I think a permanent stain. I think it's very hard to
remove. And I do think that it I think it certainly affects his
liar coverage, which is the main thing he's been doing. I think
if he does release a video, which is what he said he's going
to do, it's like, well, we know how biased you are and how emotional
you are about this topic. though how that how much can I trust
the information you're giving out? Depends what's in the video.
It might be a very good video. I don't know. But I don't know
what it looks like cuz there are still there are always people
who are going to justify this and he's still got like the icy
community behind him who want to frankly see him continue crashing
out.
Well, and there's Yeah, that's true. Um
I just in the middle of that I don't I don't disagree with you.
I agree with all that. as long as you keep your channel going,
you're a creator forever and all of this. Okay, but you just
made me think of something kind of
I just realized that um he might have another reason to make
a comment like the dickers, why didn't you take my I wish you
would have taken my phone away comment. And he might think after
this, hey, I wish you guys had like kind of held me to account
cuz I have a feeling he's going to go argue with Chud. And when
he goes, well, Icy's a private Discord. Chud is going to go shut
the up fsler. It's a 100 person channel. No, it's not. and he
will just he will keep saying that and never engage with an argument
like he will just set reality for Aiden, right? I notice that's
like I understand that's difficult when you're trying to treat
him like a peer and all of this. I have a feeling Chud will not
have any qualms about not treating him like a peer. Chud will
just say, "No, stop arguing this. It's you look like a like a
when you do this. Stop." Right? And I think that'll hit for Aiden.
It might not hit with you guys, right? like he just doesn't.
Aiden's a very like hierarchical person in his head. Like he
he he thinks of everything in terms of in terms of like social
hierarchies. It seems like like from Chud he'll accept that.
From Queen he'll accept that. I knew there's no reason for me
to come on and say that. He wouldn't he wouldn't care if I said
it, right? I don't know if he'd care if you or Dicker said it.
>> My baseline is this, you know,
I've been very fair with Aiden. Um,
>> and I mean again, he accepts that I I'm writing that
he's emotionally compromised and that he's and should have apologized.
Uh, there are other things he won't accept. Now, like from my
position,
I'm I'm saying it publicly to Aiden because then I've had the
conversation and I've said it, but yeah, I think it's
absurd and I think that he has lost all moral high ground. I
almost, I'll be honest with you, don't care what Aiden's opinion
is on that. If Aiden disagrees with me, I think he's delusional.
And if he wants to be delusional, that's fine. And if he goes
to and if Chud says that to him and that's what the turnaround
is. Um, and is this hierarchy thing, I think that's just [__]
gay, frankly, because I think that part of this is I don't know
whether this is beyond fireside chat. Like, this is just, wow,
you you've this so badly into the ground. And
the fireside chat was like the fireside chats were all the conversations
of hey you need to chill out you're becoming more you're becoming
too emotionally invested in this. And also and the other side
is like okay let's say he does hypothetically listen to Chud
well then
if your peers are telling you the other people who understand
this content and are you know co cover the ACC have covered LIO
have covered this entire community for years now and you're not
really interested in our opinions we're not really pairs that's
kind of that that would almost be like well cool any can do what
he wants but if if Chud's the thing where it's like oh well now
I need to do other things it's like well Cool.
I guess that's the that's the end of the relationship really.
Aiden needs to work it out for himself. He can't just be told
by Chud because that's just it. That's if anything even worse.
That's even gay. >> Yeah, it is gay. I do think it's going
to happen though. I I fully Well, he might he might disagree
with Chud or he might just like he'll just have to leave, right?
Like I I think that with Chud it will be like you can you can
disagree with this but then you should just go because we're
not going to go any further.
>> Yeah. I mean, like, I saw Chud a bit of Chud's coverage
there, and Chud was like, "Well, I blame Becket, whatever." Uh,
and he I don't think he's serious, but like in this case, really
not my fault. I've warned Aiden.
I've warned Aiden about like this content getting involved in
it. >> About staring into the abyss. >> He really
did stare into the abyss, didn't he?
>> Yeah.
I mean, again, it's caught me out as well. Like this this is
what happened with the Kumo stuff around Jar.
Um, and as much as people want to say like I'm compromised with
Lio,
um, like I'm careful with Lio, I guess, but I've never stopped
criticizing the stuff he's done previously. I just think it's
important to be accurate about what we're criticizing for, which
by the way is the standard I hold for literally >> Hold
on. Do you Wait, do you care about being accurate? Cuz I feel
like you fullon came in here and told me he never said he like
the minor wasn't even in the call. There's never been any indication.
And you like scroll the end of that same VOD that you were talking
about and he does give an indication that he told the minor this.
>> Yeah. Like so >> one of his friends. >> So
you say hold on but you said you were accurate. It seemed like
you stopped looking for information once you got the answer you
wanted.
>> No cuz that that call is from ages ago. Um that's not
new information.
Like what I go by is Jordan's own statements and everything else
that has happened around that. Now again, I could be completely
wrong here, but it needs more than an one off-hand comment from
Lio Convoy
um in a hostile call where he can misspeak in a story like that
that has been covered to death. This isn't some new piece of
information. The Jordan call and the Jordan story has been covered
to
Like, it's been it's been discussed multiple times. And I don't
just have that to go by. I have the actual call where they're
discussing it to go by >> where they discuss why they can't
do the thing that like in that call says oh you know
um
>> so sorry are you in the presentation >> I'm listening
but are you in the
>> yeah I'm watching >> Wait am I even presenting
>> yeah no I'm watching these women >> got knocked
the [__] out
>> Holy sh
>> bro women can't throw punches like that what the
Hold Watch this one more time. Watch this one more time.
>> Holy [__]
Holy [__] >> I think though to be quick with
this like the accuracy of the statement I'd argue here is like
the production of or the idea that Leo is like a risk to children
or a groomer or whatever. I think these are serious accusations
and you should handle them very carefully.
>> Whereas there were other things to criticize with Jordan
like the fact that Lio moved these people into his house. He
did the whole adopted family thing, all that [__]
>> which is fine to say. It's true.
>> I didn't want to like dude, I also didn't want to do
the um
I'm not like trying to defend anything around see stuff. I think
it's like all bad, but like for Aiden to describe it that way
when I don't think anyone had done enough work to know whether
or not he'd gone through like the steps and it sounded like from
what she said he'd gone through enough steps, but I don't know
what the truth is of the the steps he took. It's like if he truly
thought that was the last resort to call that like adv to just
call it in a vacuum advocating for the production of it's like
dude you're out of your mind I'm sorry like basically and like
I said Aiden admitted that there was a line where which he would
say okay yeah recording is required now right but that's obviously
true
and so the conversation argument saying
should never have been involved with it in the first place
>> like why the [__] was involved you I don't
I don't >> It's a copout argument though.
>> Well, cuz No, but like hold on. But like >> for
for Aiden, that's just a copout argument. It's like he still
thinks it happened, right? Or whatever. He thinks it's accurate
to say this. >> She just swing at a cop. [__]
>> Um Okay. Yeah, sure. I can see where you're coming from.
Um >> yeah, it's just like it doesn't actually engage with
the conversation. Well, I suppose there's the baseline thing
there of if you've got situations
where people
what's a way to put this? There is so much to criticize about
Leo Convoy that there are certain things where like if you're
relitigating them in a light where not even the people involved
with that story are making those claims. And that's the case
with a lot of this coverage that's happening now is like
this happened years ago. The Jordan call is years ago.
This is not yesterday.
This is, you know, a completely the community was completely
different. The people who were involved in this story are like
largely speaking not around
So you've got this problem where
Aiden comes up relitigates this.
Doesn't have as much information most of the time as the rest
of us do um or the wider context of things that are going on.
And
it's frustrating
because it's like Aiden becomes like the Lio convoy hater community
expert, but like there's been multiple of these. Vlad used to
be this. You know, Vlad was the like Lio convoy a logger for
the longest time.
>> The Gilded Pooh guy. >> Yeah, that was that's
>> you know that guy made a video like totally lying about
Queen, right? >> I don't want to litigate the Queenman
video.
I that that's the problem is I would have joined that. I would
have just been pressing people on other stuff again. I it would
have been like a total waste of time. But it's like hey oh also
dude this all comes down to the Willy thing. Aiden said he like
didn't follow the Willy Mac thing. I'm pretty sure he did like
eight different I think he did like four streams referring to
the Willy Mac stuff. Like I think I think he's just straight
up lying when he said oh I don't know about the Willy. Dude,
you're just lying. There's so many times where he's just lying.
like objectively lying. Like it is again just straight up throwbacks
to the Tom Foolery thing where it's just like actually
like pathologically lying. Oh, I don't know much about the Willy
Mack thing. Bro, I just looked at your I just looked at your
film. Multiple streams like the day of the day after Auggie covering
it like references all over the place to this video or videos
around it.
>> Yeah, he obviously knows what was happening during that.
I I don't know why he lied about this. I've got no idea. It's
a bizarre choice. It's a bizarre choice.
Yeah. I don't know. I don't know. I think um maybe he's cooked,
maybe he's not. I think if he I think if he takes a step back
and just like has a break, he'll be fine.
Um
>> but being like being this emotional has clearly compromised
him. So,